et bienvenue pour cette deuxième journée
des demi-finales du Global cheesecom
Championship ça lui Fab
celui qui est salut à tous
carro arrive avec sa belle chemise
tigrée panthérée sa musique dans les
oreilles obligatoires pour jouer pour
bien jouer dans standard alors si j'ai
bien écouté ces deux nouveaux guerrier
et Sarine le match principal mais je
suis je suis pas sûr en fait je suis pas
sûr de moi donc on va quand même
attendre pour voir mais c'est quand même
je pense aujourd'hui Fab largement le
match d'icaro
Nakamura qui est quand même plus
intéressant vu que c'est serré serait
quand même la grosse surprise qui Caro
gagne pas ce tournoi complètement mais
écoute il est pas enfin il y a juste
égalisé il est pas derrière mais sauf
lui donne du fil à retordre ah bah ça
pour il entend il en retard du final il
va plus rester beaucoup d'eau non non
donc ouais ben on va voir ça on va on
attend comme comme souvent j'ai envie de
dire dans dans ce tournoi on est souvent
en attente en fait
pourquoi pas
quel dommage ce matin Fabien cette
pénalité là sur les 35 m le c'est un peu
loin donc quand même ouais c'était un
peu loin ouais mais c'était normal de la
tenter ah bah oui
[Musique]
quel dommage
mérité mieux ça mérité qualification
de l'équipe de France
qui a tout donné Fabien sur le terrain
ce matin
du côté de la Nouvelle-Zélande dans
l'autre bout du monde exactement ah non
on a suivi ça on s'écrivait pendant
sortir un énorme match hein complètement
ouais
les ailières là elles étaient
rentrés en deuxième mi-temps
c'était beaucoup trop
et c'est beaucoup trop Fabien
mais bon ça mérité et en fait c'est même
pas sur la pénalité je trouve que on
doit avoir de la déception c'est sur
cette dernière action quand on va jouer
sur l'aile qu'elle remet intérieur
c'est tellement pas loin
elle peut elle peut elle peut pas garder
le ballon le lâcher sur l'aile et
peut-être qu'il y a peut-être que sa
fille la dame
de toute façon les anglaises ont gagné
oui bon après on sera les jeux contre
les anglaises en finale et puis on
aurait vu enfin c'est pas grave en fait
tant pis enfin il gagne elle gagne mais
ça aurait été une victoire incroyable
contre les quintuple championne du monde
à l'extérieur ça aurait été magnifique
hein
mais bon c'est la vie puis ça aurait
couronné une sacrée performance aussi
c'est ça
c'est tu as l'impression que c'était
mérité quoi
sur ce que sur ce qu'on a montré
complètement
mais bon c'est comme ça
en tout cas c'est le sport qu'on aime
Fabien qui offre des émotions c'est
intéressant à suivre c'est agréable et
voilà il y a pas à rougir d'une des
fêtes comme ça
c'était sympa non c'est cool c'était
bien ce jouet ça se bat bien c'est très
sérieux quoi complètement pas là pour
ça fait pas semblant quoi
ça donne tout sur le terrain
ouais mais bon c'est
quand même très sérieux
et dynamique après peut-être que elle
aurait préféré un format tu vois
ça aurait été un tour en échec
8 heures de match derrière il y avait
encore le temps de remonter
sur 80 minutes peut-être mais sur deux
semaines et demi de match avec 15
minutes de jeu et 30 minutes de pause
derrière bon on est peut-être plus fort
enfin j'en sais rien moi bah oui et puis
imagine tu leur fais écouter de la
musique pendant le match bah oui bon
déjà normal là au lieu de jouer sans
musique sans rien bon c'est pas la même
rien n'en sait rien en fait
ils font commencer les matchs à l'heure
bah je sais pas n'importe quoi aussi
imagine le machin
à 7h30 bon ça commence à 8h15
il y a quand même beaucoup de choses qui
font que oui ça n'a absolument aucune
valeur
c'est pas vraiment un essai cascade non
plus
elle est sous pression il y a un ballon
le ballon
se coucher dessus mais bon on va dire
que je sais pas une petite déception
aussi sur le premier essai qu'elles
encaisse il y a un dégagement là au pied
direct en touche
fin mais bon je remonte le pied c'est
pas facile quand même mais
quand additionne tout à la fin [ __ ]
pas loin quoi ouais et puis aussi la
transformation calmée de bord de la
blague la joueuse je pensais pas qu'elle
allait mettre
Dan Carter quoi donc automatiquement
j'ai des bons conseils c'est beau quoi
bravo
on verra si on peut battre les
Canadiennes pour la troisième place mais
bon de lui le troisième place elle
respecte pas du tout la fille qui était
l'exoise de l'équipe de France à
respectent pas du tout match absolument
rien à [ __ ] c'est pas que nous en fait
comme nous
bah comme nous les échecs du considère
même pas en fait
tu as perdu ta peur
[Musique]
maintenant il arrive
c'est beau de pas savoir pourquoi tu
joues en fait
mais après généralement ils en profitent
pour faire jouer un peu les tu te revues
d'effectifs ouais les ceux qui ont moins
celles là pour pour le coup qui ont
moins joué
c'est pareil chez les hommes
c'est un peu ça
de faire participer tout le monde à la
fête et c'est normal c'est pas une telle
déception ça doit être difficile de
retourner 4-5 jours après
le temps
ça on joue quoi et pourquoi bah on joue
le Global chat Championship et on joue
quatre parties et le programme je suis
pas de te le donner exactement parce
qu'il est complètement aléatoire mais il
y aura quatre parties mais je peux pas
te donner les heures parce qu'en fait
c'est à peu près chacun
aurait déjà dû commencer en fait depuis
8 minutes alors je sais pas pourquoi ça
a pas commencé
parce qu'ils ont fait démarrer l'autre
match non un poil avant pas démarrer non
plus à moins qu'il y a un bug mais je le
vois pas démarrer non plus alors je vais
vérifier qui est pas un bug mais pour
moi les matchs n'ont pas démarré ah
l'autre match a démarré il y avait un
bug ben je peux enfin j'y peux rien en
fait c'est le truc mais pas démarré en
fait il y avait un bug il bug ça bug
bon mais de toute façon nous on est là
pour suivre l'autre match donc ça les
limites pour le moment farine guérit on
verra le résultat nous on attend le
match enfin principal pour nous
principal mais secondaire en fait
mais nous on attend on attend du coup le
début de sauna K
après on n'a jamais vraiment compris
les horaires des matchs en fait
non au début il y avait 5 minutes
d'écart on s'est passé à 10 j'ai
l'impression que ça même changé en cours
d'événement donc ouais on sait pas bon
chaque jour un petit peu plus chaque
fois il y a eu un petit peu plus d'écart
ouais
donc on attend
le début des hostilités
d'orange tu prends après bien orange ça
dépend est-ce que c'est du kaki pomme
enfin ça dépend du kaki mais si c'est du
kaki normal il faut préférer du bocaki
même si c'est plus cher j'ai le même
problème ce matin en fait au marché j'ai
pris du kaki il s'appelle comment le
kaki normal en fait elle s'appelle juste
kaki mais en fait ils ont en fait ils
ont inventé deux autres sortes de kaki
ils ont inventé du cas qui pomme et
encore un troisième truc de kaki qui est
un peu entre les deux
framboise quoi mais alors que enfin bon
moi je les reconnais enfin spécialiste
de kaki tu me il est beaucoup plus mou
c'est ça
qui pomme on m'a dit comment le manger
donc je sais comment faire si jamais
tiens c'est les chaos qui a les blancs
comment tu fais alors faut le manger en
petit cube
tu les plus si tu coupes des petits
trucs
non mais en fait je trouve pas mauvais
en soi mais le problème c'est comme
comme avec le saumon fumer quoi une fois
que tu as connu l'autre qui acquis
tellement au dessus que c'est la merde
après c'est des sortes différentes oui
mais jamais manger du caca normal
donc servir du kaki pomme tu vois oui
bon ça va enfin c'est rien
d'extraordinaire mais c'est correct quoi
ça va mais là quand tu es habitué au
bout délicieux fondant et succulent du
gars qui normal c'est quand même
terrible de partir là-dessus quoi ah bah
moi j'achète absolument jamais de kaki
pas moi
ça m'intéresse absolument pas enfin les
rafaux je suis rattrapé du kaki pomme
j'étais dégoûté mais
mais mais moi je sais pas j'ai du mal à
dire parce qu'en fait j'ai toujours
connu pour moi le kaki pomme ça n'existe
pas en fait
si tu veux je ne respecte pas le cas qui
pomme non plus mais le truc incroyable
c'est qu'on va beaucoup plus dans le
commerce quoi du cas qui parle bah c'est
pour ça que les gens n'aiment pas le
kaki ouais c'est un scandale
alors que normal quoi faites pas votre
invention débile quoi après je pense que
ça se garde vraiment pas très longtemps
que c'est un peu trop mûr ça se détruit
très facilement
[Musique]
donc je pense c'est juste pour des
raisons commerciales c'est trop
compliqué à transporter trop compliqué à
conserver donc il préfère te vendre le
cas qui pomme quoi
là c'est encore les commerciaux qui font
chier comme pour les formats du
speechestre c'est un peu ça ouais après
sauf que c'est un vrai fruit qui existe
de base je pense le kaki pas
à cause de A4
ne me fais pas des dire ce que
c'est encore une énième écossaise
c'est terrible parce que on en a parlé
je l'ai repéré quand la Coupe d'Europe
ce coup ouais j'avais bien envie de le
jouer moi-même mais sauf comme je joue
jamais c'est con il joue tout le temps
bah il le joue tous quoi et il me grille
la politesse et le jour où je serai là
pour le jouer je me prendrais 25 coups
de théories je vois rien quoi ça sera
l'horreur
c'est terrible c'est absolument terrible
aussi et il a pas à jouer dans les pas
de visite
the little Gans
ok oui
la F3 on va complètement dégoûté dans
les écossaises quand j'ai pas le
foot casse blanche quoi
même
[Musique]
je respecte pas du tout ce qui est des
deux alors
normalement ça va pas être la révolution
mais bon au moins pareil je veux une
partie du jeu d'échecs après par contre
je serai très heureux de Madame en F3 je
suis très heureux de la structure de
pions enfin je suis heureux de certains
trucs quand même
après oui
mais bon tu es là tu as oublié tes
petites tours je vais faire ça qu'une
berlinoise
on va voir comment il la traite ça se
trouve c'est une autre manière de jouer
quand même que les Blancs c'est plus
agréable même si la jauge ne juge pas
du tout
j'aurais fait à 4 moi j'aurais fait
j'aurais pas du tout respecter à 5
j'aurais fait ça à 400 trop réfléchir
mazor est fait à 4 aussi non mais en
fait surtout que quand tu connais la
partie de visite il a gagné tellement
simplement comme ça
quatre il est fait KF3 il a monté sa
dame il a fait tout redeuse
ça c'est un peu changé il a fait dames
ces trois double attaques sur A5 et G7
il a gagné un pion
quoi contre orientari après contrarié
c'est pas non plus
non mais bon tu dis tiens je vais faire
pareil enfin est-ce qu'un chat joue
mieux que rien ne t'arrives mais après
tu auras la réponse peut-être que oui en
fait c'est un chat est plus fort qu'un
plot
qui
a parlé de Damien ce matin
sur sa chaîne
et il lui a dit oui enfin
il suit un peu d'amis en fait il se dit
oui bon
c'est beaucoup plus impressionné par mon
niveau aux échecs que par l'Australie ce
soir
l'Australie on va aller concasseries aux
échecs c'est vraiment fort
il a pas tort
ça se peut en fait j'ai un rêve
d'organiser un match entre Damien penaud
et Kingsley coman quoi
ce serait quand même
c'est facile d'avion c'est très facile
mais du coup faudrait pouvoir faire ça
et qu'ils aient un niveau pas trop
éloigné aussi bon je pense que si jamais
Damien est un peu moins fort c'est pas
très grave ça va aller mettre des
caramels c'est plutôt ouais c'est plutôt
l'inverse qui sera inquiétant
[Musique]
ce serait sympa une rencontre rugby foot
autour des échecs complètement toi tu
seras à fond pour koman et moi je suis à
fond pour
pour peu non quoi chacun défendrait ça
paroisse
au fait
pour crasso quand même quoi
il a du mal à revenir bien sûr mais en
fait il était censé être très bon quoi
du coup c'est pas évident
il y a des cons sur les séries d'échecs
qui lui chie dessus quoi
donc j'ai pas envie de me [ __ ]
complètement de sa gueule enfin un mec
qui fait tout ce qu'il peut puis bon bah
il peut pas grand chose mais il se bat
bon bah voilà
je préfère ça que un mec qui marche sur
le terrain rien à [ __ ] moi ça c'est
avec tous les jours de santé sont
toujours dire ça en fait ça fait des
saisons que sans dire ça et qui sont
nuls qui mouille le maillot je peux trop
rien dire en fait c'est hyper inquiétant
bah c'est inquiétant pour le club
d'avoir ce discours bah c'est sûr que tu
as que des mecs en fait leur seul espoir
c'est de se battre le transpirer
non mais lui en fait il aurait été fait
pour autre chose puis il essaye mais
c'est dur
non mais je comprends enfin je comprends
tout à fait ce que tu dis c'est c'est
beau dans l'abnégation dans le dans le
combat dans les valeurs
exactement valeur du 15 quoi
plus en fait tu es plus tu es plus
tranquille en fait
tu te retrouves plus dans les valeurs de
combat c'est beau quoi
parce que ce matin du coup tu t'es
retrouvé quand même dans les dans les
valeurs des Françaises
ouais bon après je regardais sans être
enfin je regarde mais
tu as senti la solidarité le non non
[Musique]
ça c'est normal mais genre tu as quand
même senti le les valeurs quoi
complètement non non mais là c'est rien
à se reprocher ok quelques petits trucs
ici là qui sont mais c'est pas dans
l'état d'esprit c'est des détails on
sait comme ça tu vois après les
néo-zélandaises elle gérait pas super
bien non plus c'est trop d'envoyer de
jeu elles étaient stressées ça se voyait
qu'elle réussissait pas au début
de l'année c'était pas toujours propre
mais elle voulait nous faire exploser en
fait
les fautes même les jeux au pied ratés
machin et tout en fait c'est c'est du au
rythme hein c'est du hors rythme
ouais ouais on a quand on était mené de
8 points et une énorme réaction elles
ont elles ont elles ont pas baissé
pavillon enfin c'est
elles en avais absolument rien à [ __ ]
elles sont retournés
un truc c'était de c'était de gagner le
match
vous savez qu'aux échecs on ressent
moins ce truc là malheureusement
en fait ce qui fait chier aux échecs
c'est une position de merde tu as beau
voir date façon le mal est fait quelque
part ça plus trop de toi enfin ça peut
mais bon il y a pas que ok tu t'es fait
bouffer un pion mais on se bat et enfin
ouais tu te bats mais bon si l'autre se
bat mieux c'est fini enfin ouais c'est
un peu chiant ça tu te traînes ton truc
quoi c'est pour ça que j'aime bien les
les matchs en Bleach il y a des parties
qui s'enchaînent et tout comment tu peux
te battre
trois points tu dis ok quoi c'est enfin
je mets des barbels quoi
alors que tu as ça dans plein d'autres
sports
[Musique]
ou n'importe quoi avant tu te fais
défoncer mais tu t'accroches tu essaies
de choper un jeu de faire un peu tourner
le truc tu changes tu joues moins tendu
plus bon mais plus ça puis bon peut-être
l'autre fois et te défonce quand même
mais ou pas ouf mais tu as pas ça aux
échecs en fait si tu t'es fait défoncer
au début tu avais les Noirs bah ouais
peut-être je suis obligé ton cahier de
manière plus bombée après mais bon ça a
rien changé quoi fin
cruel comme jeu
c'est pour ça que ouais des matchs envie
de c'est pas mal parce que justement là
tu peux adapter tes ouvertures tu peux
tu as plus de ça
bah ça ressemble plus à un sport quoi
mais donc faut faire plus de parties
moins longue ça ressemble plus à ce
qu'on veut faire ce que Bronstein
voulait faire ce que plein de gens
veulent faire depuis longtemps
après vous dites ça quand tu es largué
en sport il y a plein de cas où c'est
perdu sauf miracle aussi enfin bon tu
mets une balle dans le filet ton match
est pas fini une pièce c'est terminé
enfin c'est au foot tu prends un but pas
fini
bon enfin un moment tu auras du réagir
avant et puis si en face c'est trop fort
c'est trop fort ça arrive aussi ça et
que ce soit des échecs le foot le tennis
le rugby tu te fais rouler dessus parce
que ça joue trop bien en face mais
mais des fois niveau équivalent nos
échecs quand tu as fait ta connerie
c'est trop tard en fait bon ben au
tennis un niveau violente
ça va pas tu peux encore quoi
et du coup les échecs c'est plus
un sport martial comme de la boxe ou
quoi
tu as un œil fermé enfin bon bah tu as
beau essayer de tenir debout en fait
c'est fini quoi
et pareil si tu as fait un très bon
combat carrément tu trouveras un chaos
c'est fini aussi quoi comme là tu fais
une très bonne partie tu défonces tu
dois être gagnant machin tu convertis
merde tu as bien un truc tu perds une
pièce bah tu as perdu
donc les échecs c'est plus en mode
comme c'est joué c'est plus en mode
combat
bref non mais tu vois si on devait faire
un rapprocher quoi mais on pourrait le
rendre différent avec justement plus de
parties plus courtes et qui est cette
dimension là
une partie c'est pas grave en fait tu
préfères pas la perdre mais que bon bah
tu peux revenir et que c'est indépendant
du reste ça a pas influé tu peux jouer
d'autres parties bien les jouer et
repasser devant égaliser ou quoi d'abord
et
de faire dans les matchs champions du
monde sauf que c'est tellement long que
oui mais le problème c'est que c'est 8h
la partie donc en fait
[Rires]
[Musique]
ça serait genre des sept en 30 jours
quoi enfin oui bon tu as bien le temps
de revenir certes
ce qui se passe dans cette partie entre
Hikaru et Wesley
bah je sais pas c'est pas clair en fait
enfin
s'il se passe pas énorme mais il peut ça
peut quoi dire qu'il y a un déséquilibre
les pions sont plus trop symétriques il
y a de au centre de Halle les blancs
passés à les Noirs puis ont passé des
bons plutôt les colonnes centrales enfin
je préfère plutôt les blancs mais après
les blancs aussi mais bon si un jour tu
commences à te faire fixer tu te rends
D4 ça te ferme ton fout tu peux te
retrouver mal aussi
tu fermais le fou après C4 une fois que
tu as voulu le cavalier là peut-être que
B3 sera plus faible puisqu'elle donnera
ouais c'est pas pas trop simple à juger
en fait c'est vraiment plus ou moins
équilibré d'ailleurs on va suivre la vie
de la jauge qui qui jauge égale
on prendrait tous les deux les blancs à
choisir
mes trois grosses tubes oui non en fait
enfin donc oui
après le truc c'est que tant que les
deux tu le défends bien et il est dur à
attaquer parce que tu as pas de pièces
légères qui vont venir l'attaquer
facilement donc après un plan des Noirs
ça pourrait être de essayer d'échanger
ce cahier des deux mais bon vous trouvez
comment ou en profiter s'il part etc
donc voilà donc c'est potentiellement
une cible c'est un pion
de la structure il est faible mais après
faut trouver comment et je il y a pas de
plan simple pour aller le taper parce
qu'en même temps toi tu as des pions
pendant au centre et ça aussi tu vas
mobiliser des pièces dessus donc
j'imagine c'est dynamiquement équilibré
chacun sa faiblesse quelque part
coupe logique pour moi serait Dar F3
peut-être un kyste je sais pas un truc
un peu tactique
des trucs
et j'ai l'impression qu'il veut forcer
des quatre en fait
non
comme ça que je le comprends après je
comprends rien mais non mais c'est ce
qu'il veut faire mais je veux juste dire
j'aurais pas aimé forcer des quatre
sur des cas peut-être que le mercure
enfin je sais pas c'était le meilleur
mais c'est le plus logique
d'envoyer des cartes quand même ça
m'aurait quand même fait suer et du coup
j'aurais pas eu envie de le provoquer je
me serais ok s'il le fait mais que je
suis dans le bon tempo ça va mais
j'aurais pas eu envie de lire les deux
temps pour le faire
mais après je sais pas si j'ai raison ou
si j'ai tort hein femme
spéciale donc on verra il a bien
réfléchi pour le faire en tout cas
peut-être il serait pas trop d'idées
sinon aussi il faut dire il a fait un
peu à contrecœur je sais pas
il y a des matchs de rugby cet aprèm
ouais ouais
il y a plein de trucs
mais j'ai pas le ça passe sur bein Pays
de Galles Nouvelle-Zélande donc je peux
pas le voir c'est à quelle heure en ce
moment il y a 29 21 pour la
Nouvelle-Zélande qui semble dominer mais
j'ai pas BeIn Sport 3
chez moi je l'aime mais pas là
mais je crois qu'il domine de la tête et
des épaules les nausées
à 18h30 aussi et l'Italia battu les
Samoa 49 à 17 j'ai dit c'est un peu le
renouveau de cette équipe italienne
c'est beaucoup quand on dit ça non
c'est pas leur leur leader d'équipe mais
un peu à l'image de ce cap ou au dos qui
qui marque un petit peu la nouvelle
génération du rugby italien là qui qui
est en train de fleurir avec aussi
garbitie que tu que tu suis peut-être
qui joue à Montpellier
[Musique]
ils ont un renouveau une nouvelle
génération italienne qui va peut-être un
petit peu redorer le poison de cette
Squadra qui en a bien besoin on a parlé
dans un moment Fabien de
de les exclure en tout cas de les faire
tourner avec d'autres équipes dans le
dans le 6 nations notamment les
Géorgiens qui poussent aussi
mais là les Italiens semblent de nouveau
avoir trouvé une équipe
un peu plus compétitive descente
descente plus
ils en avaient bien besoin
normal ils se font laver tous les ans
bon cette année ils ont quand même battu
le Pays de Galles et ils ont gagné deux
matchs cette année
peut-être non
plus mais ce pion il va pas suffire
normalement il est bloqué non ce pion a
de
pas obligé de rentrer là-dedans
les trucs qui qui
ouais
c'est son seul objectif dans sa vie en
fait mais c'est dommage ouais bah il
peut faire mieux non mais surtout qu'à
force de faire ça ils vont perdre une ah
bah c'est sûr
[Applaudissements]
enfin quand il a vraiment des chances de
gains
quand il est quand il est ouais il est
moins bien autant donc la faire tourner
comme mère la finale de cavalier ou quoi
qu'il a quand même pas perdu mais
c'était pas loin et ça sent mauvais en
fait de faire ça à chaque fois il va
finir par contre ouais
tu défends quoi donc tu remets
alors que là il y a pas de raison en
fait il avait un truc il pouvait faire
des quatre qui est dessiné je sais pas
tu gagnes en fait on verra bien ce qui
se passe mais c'est pas obligé
c'est dommage
qu'il fait parce que c'est vraiment il
veut doit faire nul ça parce que le pion
est fixé il a les toit qui attaque et
bon après ils le sont trois contre 300
même je pense pas qu'il soit moins bien
mais
disons qu'il y a que lui qui peut perdre
alors qu'il était dans un truc à trois
résultats et oui comme tu dis à force de
le faire ou au moment tu vas en perdre
une tu vas mal évaluer un truc tu vas
faire une connerie ou
[Musique]
un peu
moins bien c'est pas comment expliquer
enfin c'est pas moins bien mais tu es le
seul à pouvoir faire une couille quoi
il y a que les blancs
ce matin
à un moment donné tu vois quand tu es
tout le temps devant ta ligne de but ou
quoi mais il y a que toi qui peut rater
un dégagement enfin
mais au bout d'un moment tu vas
forcément commettre une erreur à un
moment donné quoi et ça va se voir plus
parce qu'en fait si tu fais une connerie
aux pieds à 50 mètres bon bah ok pierre
le ballon
est grave en fait
directement devant ton avis plus plein
centre du terrain devant les poteaux bon
ça peut jouer des deux côtés c'est très
dur à défendre
voilà c'est pareil c'est que tu as un
pion moins si tu fais une erreur bah il
va y avoir un pion passé là si les
blancs ils mettent mal la pression bah
il va juste par le pion à 4 et c'est nul
c'est ça c'est beaucoup moins grave que
l'erreur est beaucoup plus grave pour
les noirs et même
psychologiquement quoi de jouer toujours
avec la pression de devoir être précis
c'est plus compliqué quoi puis de temps
des petits pièges là j'imagine que dame
prend à quatre je sais pas si on a
vraiment mais
bon
être obligé de vérifier
d'ailleurs
j'aurais l'impression qu'il y a un
problème
je sais pas exactement ce que je fais
tomber 4 peut-être on va voir
une défense de toute façon la jauge
bouge pas et sorciers pas mais je sais
pas ce qu'on joue
OK
bon là il a vu il a vu mais en fait à un
moment donné tu fais une erreur de
calcul tu perds instantanément alors que
comme tu le dis les blancs bah il y a au
pire tu as pas vu F5 bon bah oui nul
non mais tu peux encore jouer même ce
truc nul cavalier
avec des pions sur le merci nul mais moi
je la joue moi je te la joue je te le
prie
j'accepte jamais nul dans un truc pareil
[Musique]
et défendre le fou qui est cloué et qui
pourrait être attaquer deux fois enfin
qui dit voilà qu'il l'est d'ailleurs
le truc qui est cool par contre c'est
que sur G3 il a le temps de faire tour
ah mais tu auras deux encore
c'est possible
tellement chiant à jouer ça avec les
noirs
à rentrer enfin tu as une position tu
veux faire D4 il y a des seins et ta
chance réciproque alors peut-être tu vas
la perdre mais peut-être tu vas la
gagner
pourquoi qu'elle a envie d'aller
s'emmerder à jouer un truc comme ça
oui tu vas t'en sortir mais ouais tu vas
t'en sortir une fois deux fois quatre
fois cinq fois six fois huit fois 9 fois
et la deuxième fois tu vas te prendre
une peau de banane et t'en sors pas et
tu perds le match en zéro
en tout cas le truc c'est qu'il faut
quand même gagner une à jour pour gagner
le match
et faire que des nuls à l'Armageddon à
la fin
ça peut nous stratégie gagner un match
sans gagner une partie
ouais mais bon enfin
c'est pas
c'est pas chevaleresque comme stratégie
mais bon
tu t'emmerdes quand même vachement pour
pas grand chose
c'est tellement pas obligé de jouer
aussi solide
le mot peut être lâché
pourquoi autant s'emmerder quand on peut
jouer un truc un peu double tranchant
que tu t'amuses en plus tu t'amuses pas
dans ces parties
il va
y aller nulle elle est pas très dur mais
oui tu vois c'est
mais je sais pas pas sûr peut-être
[Musique]
mais oui on verra
jamais
il y avait peut-être
[Musique]
on va voir comment il Caro essaye de
poser des problèmes j'ai assez null
terrorisme j'aurais jamais fait le truc
je pense que ça marchait pas
j'ai peur que tu te reprennes
le cloche sur la première mais je sais
pas enfin j'ai comme j'ai pris la
position exactement en tête
ça peut pas aller ouais
ça va être nul
et anis qui a gagné
la première
avant de se faire égaliser de nul et oui
c'est ça et on va voir
OK
[Musique]
ça c'est facile
non mais des fois quand tu as deux
secondes tu peux finir par peur
oui oui avec deux secondes oui mais avec
une 50 c'est facile tu regardes
il va faire tourner 4
pourquoi il a refait chacun à deux en
fait je sais pas
c'est pour ça je
4 il va essayer
non sûr que tout va mais
pas quoi
alors il va monter le roi
mais en face bon c'est quand même
un peu plus fort
c'est pas le mot un peu plus
entreprenant
non mais il a
légère domination on va dire
il est pas vraiment mal hier j'ai
l'impression qu'il pouvait mal tourner
avec sa qualité de moins c'est lui qui a
fini par jouer pour le gain
[Musique]
mais bon à chaque fois la première
je crois
il joue bien quand même
sur la première
[Musique]
bien sûr
il va rien faire
si leur arrive en G5 il serait bien
ouais et en fait le truc j'ai déclarant
un H3 il veut lui coller un échec sur la
colonnage et il peut pas passer quoi
donc c'est juste ça qui se passe donc là
ça tourne en rond à rien faire mais on
va dire c'est le danger donc la NACA
tant autre chose il veut passer vers des
4 5
voilà et donc les Noirs en fait ils
l'empêchent chaque fois de faire ce
qu'il veut alors c'est pas de méga dur
d'empêcher je veux dire il suffit de
voir tiens qu'est-ce qu'il veut ok
chiant la répétition juste pas craquer
donc là il attaques voilà le pion G3
derrière il se remet en fait à partir de
l'autre côté non tu as cours d'idée avec
les Blancs quoi j'espère juste une
connerie des Noirs tu peux rien faire
là maintenant tu peux plus bouger la
structure depuis
pas assez grand chose
OK
[Musique]
et dans l'autre partie je sais pas
curiosité comment ça s'est passé
qui était au blanc c'est un peu plus
animé comme partie apparemment
il a fait son cahier
tu avais la valeur surprise
et là
qui peut
avoir réviser
[Musique]
je crois qu'il y a vraiment envoyé une
prépa
ça sentait pas quand même
[Musique]
de l'argent en jeu donc tu peux sortir
une petite prépa sur un petit qui est
ici ce que tu
je veux dire après bon je peux pas dire
que ce soit écrasant ce qu'il est trouvé
enfin qui est ici c'est pas mauvais
mais effectivement on sent la valeur
surprise c'est moins
moins fort que le premier jour
bonne partie un Aniche d'ailleurs
compenser sera un peu dominé
tactiquement mais pas du tout il a super
bien joué
partout
[Musique]
avec les Noirs
en fait
qui reprend le lead BAFA ben écoute on
se retrouve dans un peu moins
ça marche
à tout de suite
[Musique]
et on est de retour les amis
ça va le Fab tu as pu récupérer de ses
émotions
à tenir la finale ou pas et donc ça va
là la pause m'a permis de revenir voilà
c'est super et donc bien pouvoir
commenter
la suite j'espère je pense que ça
reprendrait d'ici une petite dizaine de
minutes tu dis 15 minutes je pense un
peu rapide 20 minutes ça serait mieux
la pause bah en gros il y a 30 minutes
de jeu 30 minutes de pause en gros
c'est à peu près le format
pour ça que les joueurs sont si solides
c'est tu vois c'est pas comme les ce
matin rugby en fait ils ont bien compris
tu voulais pénalités à la main tu
laisses pas les adversaires se reposer
tu laisses pas de pause
bah oui c'est vrai
en fait elles ont dû regarder ce tournoi
et en fait
très dangereux les pauses ça permet de
récupérer les joueurs jouent bien ils
sont à fond s'ils ont bien pu se reposer
mais enfin l'entraîneur leur a dit quoi
absolument que les adversaires n'est pas
de pause il faut jouer très vite quoi
tous les ballons exactement
privilégie la qualité par rapport à la
quantité donc voilà enfin au bout d'un
moment Martin c'est la réalité aussi
genre le rugby au final il y a des coups
de vie qui ont été ratés ce matin
30 minutes pour bien s'étirer pour bien
souffler
bah du coup le coup de pied entre les
perches
bon ben on va attendre tranquillement
ensemble c'est pas de toute façon c'est
samedi on est tranquille il fait déjà
nuit chez moi oui
un peu plus tôt chez toi qu'ici mais pas
beaucoup je pense genre du côté de
Rennes et ce qui fait nuit
[Musique]
c'est bon la perche c'est vrai que les
filets de perche c'est bon
il fait nuit du côté de Nantes aussi
exactement
la France est dans la pénombre
les outre-mer probablement
un peu la matinée là ils sont bien la
plage un beau samedi excellence
les couilles ça enchaîne ma [ __ ] qu'on
tender
c'est 40 minutes de jeu non-stop
et 5 buts de pause
et au moins la pose tu les interviews
c'est des trucs comme ça c'est cool
ouais puis c'est 5 minutes pour aller se
reposer quoi
non mais après ok c'est une pause entre
les parties j'ai pas de problème avec ça
mais il y a posé pause quoi la pause ne
doit pas être plus longue que la durée
de la partie ça c'est quand même un
prérequis normalement quoi donc si tu
laisses 5 10 minutes au mec pour
souffler aller aux toilettes des
haltères et peut-être boire un café ou
un thé ou ce qu'ils veulent il y a pas
de souci mais
c'est une heure entre chaque partie qui
dure 30 minutes ça c'est chapeau
tu as quoi comme voiture j'ai pas de
voiture frère
ou alors il pourrait jouer en décalé à
la rigueur complètement décalée
j'attends et puis voilà enfin
voilà
c'est pas notre tournoi juste donc on
commande ce qui a commenté ben voilà
c'est ce qu'on fait
ouais c'est ça la rigueur on attend ça
me fera juste un peu rater la première
mi-temps de France Australie peut-être
si un Armageddon
de façon c'est pas c'est en 15 minutes
c'est long
pourri quoi
vitre arrière ouais non c'est pas moi
ça va jouer non-stop France Australie
c'est pas le bon jeu
stickers
après c'est un beau match en sauna qui a
pour le moment 5 nuls mais c'est solide
quoi
je crois que Baki va faire trois sur
trois
dans son équipe va gagner hier un peu
par
chance
parce que les Russes faisaient n'importe
quoi missippi quoi sauver la nul
[Musique]
et
il est là
il joue contre vendredi
il s'appelle le vendredi parce que
vendredi en allemand si je dis pas de la
merde mais je crois bien si quelqu'un
parle allemand dans le chat pour
vérifier
c'est
Google Translate frite
vendredi et il est très bien avec il va
gagner il est en train de pousser les
puntos ça dame il a joué une petite
française
pas de Roser aujourd'hui
il est gagnant
il a déboîté
quel est l'eau en face
2360 c'est trop simple
évidemment c'est peu mais c'est pas si
peu que ça en fait
[Musique]
les Allemands mec si mais il est blanc
il joue contre Marcus le Serbe et il
devrait gagner
plus
il est pas mal il est bien
mais en fait oui ils sont trop au dessus
quoi
Jean Marcus en fait
ça va être un mec pour Baki
de quoi il est 25 60
c'est comme le mec à 2003 tu vois que je
compte
issue enfin
ils ont une équipe trop forte par
rapport à ce qui est en face j'ai envie
de dire
pas trop fort n'est jamais trop fort
mais en fait il y a aucun doute sur le
match ça a donné quoi bon bah qui s'est
signé les gens naïdich juin 200400 Julie
joue contre un 2400 maxouglou elle est
blanche en 200500
tu vois en fait c'est chaque partie il y
a 2 300 points d'écart quoi donc
forcément tu vas cartonner l'équipe
normalement quoi
ah mais tu es content
toujours très heureux quand tu écrase
mais
disons il est pas trop de suspense
après nous l'objectif c'est juste que
Baki gagne des points alors elles sont
fous
il prend des punch
bon bref
mais ouais non Baky c'est fini
[Musique]
et donc le 13
il peut faire le tournoi plus 10
clairement je sais pas combien de ronde
dans le truc il y en a trois de jouer il
y en a 7 6 5
1 là
en réel ou en
je crois
en prévision en prévision je crois bah
là
je sais pas
ça a commencé un c'est de nouveau
cette fois-ci c'est la petite italienne
ça on a vu beaucoup aussi des italiens
comme ça là
[Musique]
ouais bon bah ces Italiens là
je sais pas si simple voilà
c'est l'info que tu lâches
non mais en fait c'est
j'ai envie de dire que jusqu'à un
certain niveau c'est juste tu sais même
pas pourquoi tu joues c'est juste pour
être Mayal enfin tu vois mais eux ils
ont tellement étudié le truc de dizaines
d'heures il y a des micro nuances et
Machin et que c'est pas c'est pas anodin
quoi chaque coup tu vois le manœuvre de
tourbillon on sait pas ce qu'ils font
quoi
je commence ce qui se passe quand il
voulait faire baissing avec les Blancs
et voir l'empêche il y a même un je
reviens je joue pas la colonne A mais
c'est pas hyper naturel de trouver ses
coups par toi-même c'est juste un musée
comme un beuh et je leur dis et
compagnie quoi dire personne j'aurais
comme ça tout seul sur l'échiquier en
ayant encore à 14h57 à ce moment-là
je suis complètement d'accord avec toi
donc voilà donc c'est des positions
comme je dis que jusqu'à
même niveau grand maître pas top top
priori ça va donner des nuits à chaque
fois parce que bon ok c'est un mais eux
ils ont des
26-52.6 ok donc il a gagné un 6
aujourd'hui en gros c'est ça
2652.6 B ouais
c'est pas mal c'est bien bravo
puis c'est cool qu'il soit motivé
juste en fait tant que le cavalier en D2
c'est un peu dangereux enfin
stratégiquement de ce qu'est vend B3 et
il peut te faire chier en C5 ou quoi là
il est parti en F1 donc c'est peut-être
le top départ au pion quoi mais bon tu
as pas la machine voilà
comme un peu tout à l'heure avec son
téléphone il est prêt à perdre de temps
pour provoquer à 5 parce que
mais je peux comprendre c'est un peu
chiant ce fou qui en A7 et à chaque fois
tu as des ABAB et bon bah ok 6 mais du
coup cette l'immobilise et puis en
détectique des trucs donc au moins bon
ça c'est réglé
pas de principe c'est un tournoi
élimination direct ils font
ils font huit parties donc c'est le
premier qui marque au moins 4 points et
demi
voilà et puis ça élimination donc le nom
final et sinon bah c'est un tournoi qui
est nouveau donc il y a pas de prestige
d'histoire ou quoi mais il y a des très
beaux prix ça te rendra très bien doté
c'est peut-être le temps le mieux doté
de l'année
en gros le principe
bon bah le format c'est élimination
directe c'est des parties plutôt rapide
15 minutes plus de secondes parcours
je sais pas voilà enfin je sais pas si
c'est assez bien expliqué ce que j'ai
dit mais s'il faut plus d'infos voilà
non ça me parle bien pourquoi ils sont
en ligne bah en fait ils jouent sur
ordinateur comme ça je suis sur
chasse.com il joue sur ordinateur
en face de l'autre concrètement et ça
pourquoi pas en fait je suis plutôt
que tu sois chez toi on sait pas trop ce
que tu fabriques
et au final jouer sur un ordinateur ça a
quand même le point positif de pouvoir
avoir des retransmissions parce qu'aux
échecs il faut dire qu'encore
aujourd'hui la technologie ne permet pas
de vraiment déplacer les pièces
[Musique]
bah ouais mais qui des fois bug
d'ailleurs bah souvent on partait rapide
alors peut-être faudra un autre truc
enfin je sais pas moi je suis pas
ingénieur donc mais j'imagine il y a
d'autres technologies qui doivent être
possible et que ça bug pas mais en tout
cas de jouer comme ça là on peut tout
suivre à vitesse réelle quoi mais c'est
clair que c'est des Blitz très souvent
on a des des fonds
de retransmettre que je vais directement
sur ordinateur en fait
ça existe pas encore
non la technologie qui existe est
tellement imparfaite que dans les dans
les faits elles ne fonctionnent pas
très bien alors après peut-être que tu
voudrais une cam au dessus avec une IA
qui s'est retranscrire ça serait tempo
j'en sais rien moi enfin j'imagine c'est
facile de trouver des trucs soit pas
juste une sorte d'aimant ou avec des
radars qui étaient avec chaque pièce je
sais pas enfin
vous y penser peut-être un coup trop
élevé pour ce que tu gagnes et j'en sais
après mais clairement
il y a matière à trouver une
amélioration et ça
si vous êtes dans le coup il y a un
marché peut-être les gars
sur une caméra c'est easy j'avais un peu
travaillé le problème de la caméra c'est
que c'est ça consomme énormément
d'énergie
en termes de batterie
donc c'est pas facile ouais mais c'est
pas c'est pas facile c'est pas facile il
y a une vraie problématique avec la
caméra
tu peux la charger mais ça demanderait
de la charger avant toutes les parties
bah tu fais de la charge pour moi la
pause quoi c'est bien ça mais pour un
truc comme ça tu pourrais mais genre tu
pourrais pas l'utiliser sur sur des
tournois
elle peut être branché
sans parler de la charger tu es allé se
brancher ouais ouais mais bon s'il
fallait la fixer sur ouais c'est c'est
les caméras c'est pas facile et le
deuxième problème que tu as en fait j'ai
travaillé sur un projet de caméra
un petit peu le deuxième problème que tu
as aussi c'est suivant la luminosité sur
l'échiquier
bon peut-être ouais ça peut elle voit
plus trop ce qui se passe
j'ai travaillé parce qu'on a travaillé
sur les problèmes on le développer c'est
pour ça que ça pas été fait mais genre
s'il y a un insecte vient dessus
non mais non mais ok on mettra un prix
posé au chassage d'insectes sur les
caméras
un insecte les poussières
s'il y a du gras qui se met dessus enfin
c'est en fait c'est tout un tas de
problématiques avec la caméra
des mini GPS sur les pièces exactement
ça c'est un autre projet qui paraissait
d'avoir une carte de de créer des
fichiers de créer un genre de carte GPS
donc ça se repère comme ça
une situation plus c'est une solution
plus
réaliste déjà
voilà bon déjà on a des idées j'ai pas
travaillé dessus donc là je parle comme
ça mais entre le GPS les cames les
machins on peut peut-être trouver un
modèle qui va marcher et peut-être on
peut l'utiliser déjà pour les gros
tournois ou tu peux mettre une bonne
lumière et que tu as un mec qui chasse
les insectes si jamais enfin
un budget de plusieurs millions pour une
événement
d'avoir un petit projecteur qui se met
de la lumière ça doit être possible
quand même
oui mais je leur parle là c'est que
c'est tellement cher à développer que si
tu peux pas le vendre commercialement
c'est pas intéressant et si c'est que
pour faire ces tournois là enfin
remarque qu'il me dirait il m'a
tellement d'argent pour oui enfin tu
vois je me dis bon au moment oui
enfin moi j'avais travaillé sur le truc
il y a 7 ans donc c'est pas les
technologies de plus avancer donc mais
c'est
intéressants les machins il y a tout un
tas à la batterie il y a tout un tas de
choses
mais d'ailleurs caméra
après quand j'ai discuté en fait il y
avait une autre idée qui avait émergé
c'était peut-être de pas utiliser une
caméra normale mais ça pouvait être une
caméra qui détectait un marqueur sur les
pièces et sur les chiquitier et que ce
soit avec ce marqueur que on
puisse avoir le développement des coûts
c'est-à-dire de pas penser en caméra
normal mais ça peut être caméra
infrarouge caméra même
comment s'appelle la thermique ou quoi
enfin bon peu importe mais essayer
d'utiliser une caméra qui repère des
marqueurs qui sont faciles à mettre sur
les pièces et qui sont pas visibles à
l'oeil nu donc qui gênent pas et qui
permettrait de d'être plus économe en
termes de batterie notamment
du coup
et moins capricieux sur les problèmes de
luminosité
on demande pourquoi il met un casque de
la musique
ils doivent écouter de la musique c'est
dans les règles c'est vraiment notre
rôle arnaque nounou
chat pour la première fois ok il
comprend pas mais c'est normal casque
puis se prend le mec qui répond bah
écoute de la musique mais c'est vrai que
de base tu peux avoir l'impression qu'on
se fait ta gueule mais c'est vrai mais
en fait c'est vrai
on sait pas pourquoi en fait c'est
ils doivent écouter de la musique voilà
c'est la règle
après il y avait aussi l'idée du coup
moi j'avais eu c'était de faire comme
aux échecs japonais donc au Shogi
c'était de faire jouer les joueurs sur
des pièces en 2D ah ouais faut que tu te
déplacerais les pièces avec les doigts
ça fait de la pression ça fait des mais
du coup si tu as une caméra au-dessus on
voit très bien la position
alors là tu peux soit utiliser de
nouveau un psgn soit carrément avoir une
la la reconnaissance caméra
Metz qui est vraiment facile
pour une Palace c'est vraiment facile
pour une intelligence artificielle
ce que t'as pas de problème de la 3D du
machin du truc
la musique est imposée ouais
mais ils ont le choix d'écouter leur
propre musique ils font ce qu'ils
veulent tu écoutes du bon damso là
ça peut détecter les appareils cachés
dans le corps voilà c'est pas dans le
corps qu'il faut chercher enfin oui
c'est dans le corps mais j'arrive il
faut être plus précis
beaucoup plus intéressant je suis pas
d'accord ils sont nettement moins forts
mais celle-là elle est pas neutre en
fait ok c'est symétrique mais
[Musique]
tu vois c'était un peu mieux pour les
blancs pour plusieurs raisons en fait
les blancs décident d'ouvrir la colonne
à ou pas avec apprendre B donc j'ai une
tension qui choisissent c'est eux qui
peut te dire je peux prendre je vais
rentrer en 7e ou je sais pas quoi ils
ont déjà la tour-render sur l'autre
colonne ouverte environ le kg 3 il peut
aller vers F5 s'il veut et le cadeau il
peut aller vers B3 C5 donc toutes les
pièces sont plutôt un peu mieux que
celle des noirs
après il va falloir frapper dans le bon
tempo quoi voilà c'est pas énorme mais
j'en sais rien si ça suffit mais je sais
pas juste un truc ou c'est tout égal ou
symétrique il se passe rien enfin ces
techniques mais
avantagement quand même
ouais c'est un bel avantage quand même
dur à convertir mais c'est sympa je dis
pas je regarde de la convertir encore
moins contre des joueurs comme ça
même je pense pas mais je saurais que
c'est moi qui j'aurais pour être mieux
tu sais que tu joues le gain quoi
et le tournoi est homologué ouais malgré
le cette présence obligatoire de musique
ce qui moi m'a étonné personnellement
oui
alors pourquoi simplement parce que ça
dénature quand même le jeu et la
concentration
non mais je te dis enfin on en parle
l'autre jour mais que tu as le droit de
jouer avec la musique si tu veux
pourquoi pas mais contre l'impose ça me
paraît fou
prenante a juste pas le droit dans un
vrai tournoi tu viens pas avec ton
casque et ton baladeur ou ton MP3 enfin
peu importe quoi c'est
carrément interdit ouais
donc normalement c'est pas le droit là
c'est l'affaire quoi normalement c'est
pas le droit là c'est là c'est imposé
donc ouais c'est un peu étonnant après
encore une fois pourquoi pas c'est
peut-être la modernité Fab
je pense ça va refaire nul
si ça lui plaît c'est le plus important
surtout il aime ça je suis même pas sûr
que ça lui plaise en fait de faire ça
enfin j'ai l'impression que c'est juste
si il arrive pas à faire autrement en
fait
il supporte pas quoi
non mais de se dire ok je peux plus
perdre aussi je vais faire à 5 le Kibi 7
il reste en B7 si il bouge fréquent ici
5 et je vais faire tourner trois dame D1
je sais pas quelque chose ou rien au
pire je suis nul
puis peut-être quelque chose
voilà par contre je sais pas ce qu'il
fait
pour toutes les changer tout faire
symétrique bon bah là il y a rien à dire
mais si tu règles le son à 0 ils peuvent
pas le voir ah mais je crois que c'est
eux qui t'oblige ils te non mais je
pense tu peux pas je crois que tu es
vraiment obligé de mettre de la musique
c'est eux qui règle le son
à côté etc il doit vouloir dire les
coups et commenter en étant à côté ils
doivent pas vouloir que que les joueurs
puissent entendre et donc il doit avoir
une double protection
en fait on monte sur la 5 il y a pas
assez simple peut-être mais bon là on
plante la tour en des cinq
et je sais pas enfin
tu dois faire à 5 tu fais pas à 5
bon voilà au moins il fait un coup pour
prétendre faire un truc c'est pas grand
chose mais voilà
ce serait beau les lacs du Connemara
quoi
comme musique si vous pouvez choisir moi
ça me saoule rien
moi ça me saoulerait au plus haut point
de d'être obligé de mettre de la musique
si c'est pour éviter la triche c'est un
peu ridicule je pense c'est pour éviter
la triche
outre la triche que tu puisses entendre
des trucs dans le public ou
peut-être s'il y a les commentaires sur
place justement tu s'entendre des
commentaires bon après en général
tu peux les mettre derrière des vitres
ou un truc insonorisé et ça pourrait
marcher aussi sans qu'ils disent de la
musique sur les oreilles mais bon je
sais pas c'est comme ça
je mettrai
de miel et live de Lost frequencies
Fab oh oui non
les blancs menacent encore ces quatre
peut-être
le bruit blanc je crois que c'est pas le
droit je crois que tu as pas le droit au
bruit blanc parce que je crois que c'est
ça a été discuté tu es vraiment obligé
d'avoir la musique arabe voilà une
petite bulle
ça fait plaisir
il pouvait faire un truc là que c'est
que ça c'est vraiment la barre elle est
vraiment complètement
la Manche d'hier quoi
c'est à dire que il y a la première il
perdu la seconde bon bah là si on en
croit la barre blanche à gauche de
l'échiquier
moi je ferai le bruit blanc
mais ça me saoulerait quand même en fait
enfin
c'est du bruit quoi c'est quoi le bruit
blanc c'est une silence c'est un genre
de bruit ouais
c'est un bruit qui bloque les autres
bruits
en fait moi juste ça me saoulerait
d'avoir un casque sur les oreilles déjà
de base
ça me fait des bouchons ça me gêne en
fait réellement
ouais donc là ouais mais il est pas trop
bien parce que il est un peu les pièces
mais n'importe comment avec les mains en
plus il y a une Torah
c'est un peu la merde quoi
je sais pas comment il s'est retrouvé là
c'était quoi le début
je comprends pas ce qui fait en fait
tu prends du cheval en fait
trop de créativité sur la créativité
c'est n'importe quoi en fait c'est pour
ça vous dites belle partie mais en fait
c'est de la merde ouais enfin je
comprends c'est belle partie parce qu'il
y a une victoire mais la partie en soi
c'est mieux jouer ce qu'il fait enfin
c'est insipide mais il y a pas d'erreur
est vraiment moche je sais pas pourquoi
il était comme ça en fait
est tranquille solide et c'est lui qui
est un peu
envenimé les débats
ouais mettre de la musique qui lui plaît
quoi
c'est énervé quoi il écoutait il
écoutait du damso quoi
il a mis du damso à fond et il suit
oui
même bouger ta dame en fait tu t'en fous
tu le laisses là au milieu des Français
je sais pas quoi
[Musique]
ça va être un coup de grâce
8 et tu auras étant G8
qui va arriver malgré tout
belle victoire je passais le mot mais
victoire écrasante de Daniel side dans
cette partie qui égalise 3 3 dans les
deux matchs trois partout ouais
l'égalité parfaite on va sûrement aller
vers un Armageddon un Fab aujourd'hui
j'ai raté France Australie ça nous fait
bien plaisir tout ça
alors Fab c'est la pause c'est déjà la
pause ça va vite ça va très vite
aujourd'hui pause ouais pause de 40
minutes quasiment là
mais bon faut se remettre après le parti
ou l'autre tu vois c'est quoi un
Armageddon un Armageddon on a marqué
dans un Armageddon c'est une partie où
les Noirs ont moins de temps mais s'ils
font nul ils gagnent
en gros
les blancs sont obligés de gagner c'est
ça
normalement c'est un intérêt quand il y
a peu de temps c'est à dire que en fait
les blancs consacré plus de temps et
donc vont mettre la pression et à la
position parce que tu commences à jouer
donc tu t'es un peu mieux quoi du coup
par principe et de deux aussi parce que
c'était mieux autant par contre le
défaut c'est que si l'autre défend bien
il fait nul ben
perdu quoi tu es obligé de gagner quoi
est-ce que là c'est Armageddon non il
reste encore deux parties à jouer mais
bon comme les deux scores sont égalité
on imagine que au moins sur l'une des
deux parties il y aura Armageddon
mais c'est pas encore fait c'est pas
encore fait donc on va
on va faire une pause
et on va revenir dans 25 30 minutes Fab
allez à tout à l'heure à tout de suite
les amis merci
à tout de suite pour la suite
[Musique]
bon les amis je crois qu'on a perdu Fab
Fab qui est tombé dans la nuit je pense
qu'il doit regarder la fin de
Joko en fait
gagner par Djoko dans le tie-break du 3e
et j'imagine qu'on va le
retrouveront
enfin tu me diras les joueurs aussi
enfin là c'est
c'est le grand festival en fait il y a
tout le monde qui regarde Titi passe
Djoko la pose de face de trop pour five
il va sûrement arriver j'imagine qu'il
regardait la fin de Djoko City Pass mais
de toute façon on voit qu'il a pas
vraiment de retard puisque c'est encore
la pose totale chez les joueurs donc il
y a pas de
il y a pas de il y a pas de mal Fab qui
a rien raté en quelque sorte
Djoko vient de gagner ouais du coup
vient de gagner le tie-break 7 4 mais
non je vais pas regarder parce que si
regardez ça il serait déjà là je lui ai
écrit en tout cas
elle a peut-être eu quelque chose
quelque chose chez lui peut-être le
chien ou je sais pas ça peut hein à tout
moment
victoire de Nova quoi
c'est quoi encore la pause il y a une
tête de partie qui a qui a recommencé
mais oui sur le match que nous on suis
c'est encore la pause ouais la partie a
fini que à 18h30 donc on est on est sur
une je suis étonné que Fab soit pas là
et là il a vraiment du sang dormir en
fait un pronom pour France Australie
beaucoup plus dur que vous ne le pensez
on a perdu Fab
on a vraiment perdu Fab
ah écoutez on va on va attendre notre
partie de toute façon qui arrache quick
les vans ouais
non non mais je suis un peu étonné mais
il doit y avoir c'est pas c'est pas
l'habitude de femmes d'être en retard il
doit marquer quelque chose en fait il y
a plus du tout de lumière
chez lui et ce qu'il aurait pas perdu
panne d'électricité possible ou pas je
sais pas si Internet continue
peut-être pas d'électricité locale dans
l'endroit où est stream ou quoi parce
que c'est bizarre en fait qui soit ce
soit complètement
dragons on sait qui test c'était pas
noir comme ça chez lui
c'est ça je viens de faire un sms ouais
il peut être en 4G ouais Fab ça peut
être en 4G ouais
qui peut l'arrêter peut-être la 5G
mais je vais voir je vais l'appeler en
fait
je suis la première fois que ça arrive
en fait Fab il est jamais en retard
c'est bien une personne qui est jamais
en retard c'est le Fab
ce qui serait ouais il est peut-être
sorti à une jupe pendant la pause et il
a peut-être eu un problème ah non il est
là une femme qui a du retard c'est rare
un Fab en retard c'est rare non mais en
fait désolé je
j'avais pas l'air sur moi je regardais
le rugby
[Musique]
tout le temps
il faut que ça et quoi d'autre donc il
te rentre dedans après ils ont pris un
jaune mais bon là on a pas eu de
profiter et même il y avait une finalité
pour pour les sud-affs mais il était à
n'importe comment williamsé mais du coup
ça veut dire que ça va être dur pour la
France aujourd'hui parce que j'ai
remarqué un truc généralement parce que
les Gallois se sont fait défoncer par
par la Nouvelle-Zélande
ils ont pris 50 55 à 25 ou un truc comme
ça enfin ils sont fait dézinguer la
l'Irlande qui est censée être du même
niveau que la France a su contre
l'Afrique du Sud ouais et en fait sur
des dynamiques c'est là ça veut dire que
la France ça va être dur aujourd'hui
enfin on va gagner physiquement l'autre
sont prêts et tout ouais puis ils
étaient peut-être un peu échaudés de des
dernières tournées ou quelque part
l'hémisphère nord
[Musique]
il suffit qu'on regarde guéri contre
les autres
B5
donc va avoir les il va avoir quelle
couleur maca
il va les blancs
mais en fait tu vois je voyais que c'est
26 minutes de jeu je me suis dit bon bah
ça conseille ennemi bah c'est bon on
tient je viens commenter
ils arrêtent l'horloge à la moindre il
faut faire très attention au rugby c'est
ça le problème d'expérience
[Musique]
donc ma carte il va avoir les noms
il va avoir les blancs ouais elle doit
avoir les blancs
[Musique]
mais non les Irlandais le match enfin je
sais pas trop ce qui va se passer il
m'en a un peu en dessous mais bon
l'Afrique du Sud n'est pas excellente au
rugby ils sont juste champion du monde
en fait donc
ça va c'est juste que leur jeu est très
restrictif en fait
ils sont très costaud quoi un jeu à base
de chandelle et de les 32 ans le ballon
ils font pas de place
maxi et bam à ses intéresse pas du tout
les passes
je crois que ça les intéresse absolument
pas ça c'est vrai
tu as un ballon tu
le donnes pour rien au monde quoi c'est
l'entraînant là de Fédérale 2 tu as un
ballon c'est c'est trop dur à gagner un
ballon quoi enfin si tu prends le ballon
il t'a racheté ma avec en fait c'est
un ballon je le donne pas quoi c'est ton
équipe et non dégage ça m'intéresse pas
c'est le mien
et Djoko qui a gagné pendant que tu
étais en rugby
mais il a gagné un point de ouf ou enfin
il y a trois moments tu penses que le
point est fini
genre oui enfin tu vas pas la remettre
ça là quand même
bon ça va refaire une petite nuit ici je
pense
ce serait bien normal quoi
on va attendre on va voir notre partie
phare qui va commencer Fab sonaka est-ce
qu'on va avoir le droit une septième nul
dans ce match
il y a des chances
[Musique]
ça ferait plaisir
un trou noir de masse stellaire
découvert à deux pas de la terre
pas trop de bonne nouvelle ça non pas de
souci t'es trompeur 1600 années-lumière
ce n'est pas à deux pas de la terre
qui est pas content quoi
900 milliards de kilomètres
comme vous l'écrivez mais bel et bien
4256 millions de milliards de km c'est
vrai que ça fait
c'est loin
[Musique]
plus de problème d'inflation
15,4256 millions de milliards de
kilomètres pour moi c'est assez long en
fait c'est
après être à l'échelle
le mieux c'est fou c'est 5
il faut se rappeler un peu après tu peux
jouer d'autres coups c'est 5
[Musique]
et là
des signes gauche je crois ou dame 7 et
des signes quoi
des 5 à y prendre profond
je sais pas il est mort donne tout mais
ils font perpète en fait mais il faut se
rappeler
on va voir si il se rappelle en fait
nous on se rappelle parking c'est des
signes Go c'est sûr ouais c'est sûr
même pas voilà
ok il faut prendre
ou attends c'est pas fou prendre
d'habitude
[Musique]
mais je pense j'ai jamais eu en fait ce
truc mais juste comme ça m'est arrivé de
faire juste les normes faisaient jamais
poussé 5 moi je sais juste parce que je
l'ai vu dans des parties que j'ai
commencé mais que les mecs se
rappelaient mais c'est tout en fait
non mais
prends le grand coup ça va me prendre
quatre mais genre là faut se rappeler
plusieurs victoires avec les blancs
tout va vite prendre et tout ça là il y
a C3
[Musique]
il prend H12
mais ça j'ai déjà vu une fois aussi je
pense
ouais mais c'est you qui joue ça des
fois
[Musique]
normalement c'est pas ouf mais au moins
tu as besoin de plus donc
un défenseur de la qualité de maca ça
peut être intéressant ouais
il joue peut-être sur sa force
bravo à lui tant mieux ça clique
de toute façon c'est
de position pour
se cacher avec le roi avec une tour
endée laisser la colonne E ouverte pour
l'autre tour
mais comment ils font à se rappeler à se
rappeler de tout ça en fait
il passe leur temps à faire ça
mais genre tous les jours et regarder
des trucs comme ça
tous les jours mais tu le fais une faute
de par semaine ça va en fait pas juste
moi je le fais jamais mais genre jamais
des trucs j'ai joué à 15 ans bon bah je
sais plus quoi enfin mais si tu fais
tout le temps bah qui révise mais c'est
pas genre hyper chiant
il va à la salle de muscu et il fait ses
exercices et
chiant en fait mais il fait quoi c'est
moins ça me paraît moins chiant
visuellement quand même
non mais c'est pour ça que je dis que
moi je veux jouer au 960 ça me fait
super chier
à réviser des trucs tu as déjà vu mille
fois tu me diras le sport c'est pareil
mais je sais pas le sport en terre en
fait le sport tu sais créer de la
dopamine quand tu le fais naturellement
ton corps est fait pour être content
quand tu fais du sport quand même
les yeux devant un écran mais c'est
horrible en fait mais non mais vraiment
enfin le 960 moi j'ai milite à fond
c'est pour les mecs Semir traités comme
moi ça fait plaisir de
en fait là tu es une partie comme ça ou
le mec t'as réussi tout et tu sais pas
tu perds mais t'as même pas jouer en
fait
fondamentalement tu sais parce que je
l'ai dans mon ordi quoi en fait mais
j'ai pas que ça à [ __ ] quoi mais donc
c'est chiant en fait passer c'est
fondamentalement
d'où le 960 intéressant mais bon ça ne
sera jamais quoi c'est comme ça
ah non mais là c'est c'est
ignoble
c'est pour ça que j'ai arrêté en fait
complètement c'est pour ça que je rejoue
même pas du tout parce que c'est devenu
comme ça enfin c'est devenu
comme ça quand j'ai arrêté quand même
c'était déjà un peu comme ça je viens de
te dire que jusqu'à milieu des années
2010 encore ça va quoi
mais c'est pire là bah moi j'ai arrêté
en 2005 c'était déjà un peu comme ça
oui mais bon les endettés moins fort etc
tu pouvais encore cliquer mais c'était
le début
mais à quel intérêt en fait de jouer
c'est comme ça
tu récites des trucs et tu ne fais plus
un coup par toi-même il y a plus
l'aspect jeu en fait c'est terrible mais
c'est vraiment plus un jeu en fait tu te
fais vraiment chier et puis un jeu
bah c'est pour ça que 960 pour nous
sauver pour des gens comme nous enfin je
te jure débute
on parle du fait qu'il faille réviser
tout un tas de lignes
femme est très non mais moi c'est pour
ça que j'ai arrêté c'est non mais très
énervé c'est un grand mot je m'en fous
bah je joue comme je vous entends et
puis voilà mais
[Musique]
c'est pénible enfin le problème c'est
que si tu le fais pas tu es d'autant
plus frustré que les autres le font et
quand tu joues tu arrives même pas jouer
quoi en fait tu il te faut c'est pas lui
qui bosse enfin c'est relou c'est comme
ça quoi mais en fait je veux juste une
position normale et qu'on joue aux
échecs
quand on sortait on te parle pas de ça
maintenant en fait c'est pas
pour la même raison donc c'est juste je
suis pas énervé parce que je suis plus
au contact
mais c'est pour ça que c'est pour ça que
tu as plein de gens qui demandent est-ce
que tu veux rejouer en long ou quoi
c'est impossible en fait je peux juste
pas
ok je joue à 23 à 23 50 mais ça a aucun
intérêt à ce niveau-là c'est ridicule en
fait d'être bloqué de 200 points et
l'eau ou de 150 ou 200 points lois à
cause de l'ouverture c'est horrible en
fait
[Musique]
faut vraiment bosser de ouf et après en
plus le problème c'est qu'il faut aussi
jouer dans le jeu il suffit pas de faire
ça mais
en fait dans le jeu bon ça irait quoi je
veux dire
c'est pas ça le problème en soi
[Musique]
mieux calculer de jouer la finale mieux
c'est pas un problème alors mieux jouer
avec moi
c'est la vie mais
perdre sur des trucs comme ça tu perds
même pas contre l'adversaire en fait
tu perds son ordi encore tu perdrais
contre des prépas qu'il a fait lui chez
lui tout seul oui bah comme dans les
années
je suis d'accord avec toi
tu as dû stylé intéressant
mais juin 1960
faut réviser comme des bottes plein la
tête passer des heures et des heures et
puis bravo à ceux qui le font face c'est
pas un souci mais c'est pas marrant et
le problème c'est un moment ça devient
frustrant quand enfin je suis pas là
pour ça mon patron ouais après tu as
réussi le dernier truc et c'est une des
raisons annexes pour lequel a arrêté
Vlad aussi
c'est qu'il avait joué dans dans les
derniers open qu'il a joué les deux à
trois dernières années il y a deux trois
open qu'il a joué qui ont été gagné par
des gens qui triché enfin lui il savait
qu'il tricher mais juste les
organisateurs s'en foutent
révisé que machin que tu as fait tous
ses efforts là qui sont insupportables
et que le mec en fait il a juste un
écouteur dans l'oreille et qui te
défonce ok là tu rages quittes le jeu en
fait à un moment donné oui bien sûr
le simple fait que plus le temps passe
moi tu es motivé non moins tu as envie
de faire ses efforts là et
que en plus bah ça devient chiant on va
dans des jouets des parties plus courtes
on va passer
et d'autres centres d'intérêt etc etc
c'est comme ça mais et donc oui moi en
gros le truc qui pourrait me redonner de
l'intérêt c'est comme je disais 960 ça
me ferait plaisir de les tournois de 960
absolument rien à [ __ ] tu es là tu
t'amuses quoi
je sais pas comment dire c'est beaucoup
plus drôle
ou des parties du matin sinon non mais
est-ce que faire jouer le matin n'est
pas une forme de triche
non en plus le truc en long moi quand
j'avais rejoué
c'est que des fois en plus tu te
retrouves les positions de merde à cause
de l'ouverture donc tu remontes parce
que tu es plus fort mais tu te fais
chier pendant 4 heures et je vois une
position de merde en fait enfin c'est
chiant en fait ta prise zéro plaisir
pendant la partie même si tu la gagnes
bon en tout cas la position elle est
intéressante pour le coup pour le coup
elle s'ajoute
pour Naka mais paire de fou en face pas
mal d'activités c'est un peu serré mais
je pense il est dans son élément
d'accueil il a beaucoup d'avance à la
pendule donc c'est
pas mal
votre travail qui passera rien moi je
pense ce sera Sarine Naka la finale et
si c'est Sarine Naka ça va être un
ton pour un carnage
laissera pas faire quoi
problème de Sarine c'est que du coup son
point fort entre guillemets il est
pas assez fort pour
par contre sur le sur le reste il est il
est bien derrière donc
bravo
chaque conseil en fait tu prends son
point Hello
là ça devrait être juste un petit livre
juste de conseil du coach en fait
voilà un bon conseil pour gagner contre
les ordis d'ailleurs
ne jouez pas non juste débrancher le
tu as perdu connard
non
en fait il y a que ceux qui a des
chances visiblement j'y croyais moyen
mais je me disais ok c'était le seul à
part Douda qui pouvait un peu tout ça il
a juste implosé on a vu que sinon il
pouvait le mettre en danger quand même
mais il a trop implosé le premier jour
et ouais bah ça il était un peu en forme
sur les derniers tournois donc c'était
plus comment dire je le sentais pas en
forme enfin tu sais que saut en forme
max il pouvait gêner mais il était
tellement hors-forme sur les Olympiades
sur les machins sur les trucs
et tout tu sais bon il a il a bien
régressé et là sur ce tournoi on
retrouve un peu quoi
peut-être que c'est un moyen de se
rassurer de jouer avec des barbelés tout
le temps quoi
[Musique]
récemment je ne sais plus lequel j'ai
pas l'impression qu'il y a un truc
[Musique]
alors il avait
un rapide mais non j'ai pas
je sais pas j'ai rien en tête mais bon
j'ai pas en tête une victoire de ça me
revient pas H3
mais attention quand même parce que ça
peut
ouais
il fait pas de gueule en fait
mais c'est bizarre parce qu'en fait les
couilles plutôt d'un macaque
[Musique]
pour un peu toucher et puis tu as touché
je comprends pas du tout
mais je comprends pas
qui avait gagné en finale contre 6
[Musique]
peut-être mais s'il y a déjà un moment
ça alors pas c'est pas en 2022 déjà
ou alors c'est tout début 2022 mais il
était peut-être déjà éliminé au moins il
a gagné en plus
et rapporte aussi du coup
[Musique]
qui était qualifié ou pas donc pas
vraiment
c'est en début d'année quoi
c'était plus le temps avait déjà plus
dangereux à ce moment-là en fait
c'est beau quand même le nom de ce parti
il y a aucun enjeu quoi aux échecs
de le jouer ce truc je sais mais genre
en fait c'est comment ça peut être tout
le temps débile enfin c'est le moins de
tournoi dont tu parles tu sais se
rappeler en fait ah mais c'est encore un
truc con mais c'est super con enfin
évidemment tu dois en faire que deux
Grands Prix et le vainqueur de chaque
Grand Prix est qualifié et puis c'est
tout en fait ouais avec les mêmes
joueurs
et ok le vainqueur d'avant il se fait
remplacer par un autre mec ok c'est tout
par le premier remplaçant mais ça
s'arrête là en fait d'où tu fais trois
grands prix ou tout le monde en joue
deux mais c'est tellement débile et tu
as les mecs après un grand prix où ils
ont fait de la merde parce qu'ils sont
démotivé ça plus rien c'est des plots
donc ils vont lâcher le truc quand ils
s'en [ __ ] quoi et tu as d'autres qui
sont à la limite très motivés puisqu'on
le tirage ça va tout changer ou enfin
c'est juste débile quoi enfin oui c'est
c'est vraiment con après bon le coup de
chance quelque part c'est que rapporte
Naka c'était mérité parce que je crois
qu'ils ont tous les deux gagnés leur
truc quoi ouais non donc en fait les
vainqueurs du Grand Prix un grand prix
de sont qualifiés donc au final le truc
qu'on voulait faire ça a marché mais là
vous avez pas besoin du troisième du
coup voilà
et quoi qu'il en soit c'était mieux de
ne pas faire de 3e mais ça a organisé
direct comme ça quoi
mais si c'était bizarre ça a aucun aucun
intérêt dans la position enfin après
c'est peut-être mieux de l'avoir que de
l'avoir j'en suis même pas sûr mais non
je pense pas je le trouve affreux comme
quoi
je vois pas un monde où c'est bien
enlève cette casse tu t'enlèves des
tours sixième qui passe
blanche il y a damasys qui vient il y a
dame G2 dame enfin je sais pas je vois
que des problèmes c'est juste visuel je
calcule pas une variante mais je
comprends pas où c'est bien en fait
ah ouais je suis d'accord avec toi
mais c'était unique et comme il est en
face de Naka il a pas voulu le montrer
parce qu'il bouge pas du tout et là il a
l'air un peu dégoûté quoi c'était
vraiment un mystique mais il a pas voulu
donner l'info c'est aussi possible
parce que de toute façon c'est assis si
c'est un autre coup
[Musique]
après comme je dis là c'est pas tout à
fait comme quand tu es chez toi avec le
mec est chez lui comme tu es en face tu
veux peut-être pas donner d'infos quoi
j'aurais peut-être fait mais c'est pas
du bouton ouais parce qu'en fait tu as
même des parents je me dis tu sais quand
tu as un damaka Damas 5 il fait B3 et le
cavalier
ça sent le mystique ou une faute très
bizarre
puisse influer sur les lots c'est quand
même bizarre
c'est vrai que
c'est le seul défaut en fait on va dire
c'est que le misclic puisse exister sont
toujours là ça va en fait
la musique en plein truc bizarre mais en
soi de faire jouer des tournois dans une
salle avec du monde en réel et que ça
j'ai pas de problème mais ouais le
problème du muscle c'est chiant parce
que ta main fait pas enfin
voilà
ça me dérange pas ça moi je trouve c'est
une évolution ça peut être une évolution
du jeu écoute moi ça m'embête pas trop
ça ça arrivera toujours une fois de
temps en temps mais c'est pas plein de
trucs dans la vie qui peuvent arriver
on n'est pas handicapé non plus quoi
enfin
il a complètement craqué mais c'est pas
musclé en fait
avec la souris le même coup c'est juste
qu'il a il a pas regardé le coup de
l'adversaire ces gens il a fait un primo
mais c'est pas qui voulait pas jouer le
coup sa main la jouer c'est qu'il a pas
je ne suis plus la dame aille chez pas
où c'est le coup logique et de toute
façon il voulait bouger son roi puis il
a mis la dame ailleurs il a quand même
bougé le roi bah merde ça perd
mais
on va dire par contre la musique ça
m'embête plus même si c'est des bruits
blancs ou quoi enfin on peu importe
bon ben faut vite non
moi je pense
[Musique]
je comprends pas la musique faites le
casque antique le casque anti-bruit les
bruits blancs je comprends pas en fait
parce que les bruits blancs je pense que
ça dérange un peu quand même enfin moi
j'ai des bruits blancs dans mon
tu sais j'ai des écouteurs avec des
bruits que tu peux mettre tu peux mettre
des bruits blancs je sais pas pourquoi
j'ai déjà essayé
c'est pas très dérangeant en soi
mais pourquoi on m'impose ça en fait
tu pourrais jouer avec un spas j'ai pas
le contraire mais
c'est relou à la longue voilà c'est ça
c'est qu'en fait
4 heures de bruit blanc par jour
ça va quoi
ils sont à la même salle que les
commentateurs non mais je comprends en
fait que c'est ça le problème enfin j'ai
compris que les commentateurs étaient
pas loin mais un peu
tu leur mets une vitre tu mets dans une
pièce insonorisée enfin tu as 1000
solutions et tu fais pas subir aux
joueurs le fait que tu es pas une [ __ ]
pour moi le seul argument qui peut
marcher pour le casque et le bruit blanc
le seul cas où je l'accepte c'est s'il y
a une sale rempli de public alors je
peux t'expliquer pourquoi
parce que on a quand même du mal à
attirer les gens dans les salles et
c'est très dur parce que
ben tu étais obligé d'être silencieux
enfin il y a tout un tas de problèmes
liés aux échecs qui fait que les gens
ont pas envie de se déplacer pour voir
des échecs et tu peux pas être animé tu
as l'impression de de ce que me disait
ma femme une fois on allait voir un
tournoi d'échec à Moscou tu sais avec
tous les meilleurs joueurs du monde et
en fait liéna elle a été elle a toussé
parce qu'elle était malade enfin elle
avait un petit rhume quoi et ça arrive
souvent c'est en hiver tu en février à
Moscou tout le monde a le rhume en fait
il fait - 32 dehors
elle a toussé je te jure il y a tout le
monde qui s'est retourné
bon ben elle est sortie de la pièce elle
a plus jamais voulu retourner voir un
tournoi d'échec mais en fait c'est
n'importe quoi en fait tu tousses tu as
l'impression que c'est
un crime c'est un crime de l'aise
Majesté bon du coup en fait dans le cas
où tu dis va avoir une publie un public
on va faire on va prendre une salle de
théâtre il va y avoir 1000 personnes
dans la salle qui vont suivre le match
et tu dis au joueur bon écoutez les gars
c'est juste que là on va changer de
format il y a énormément de public on
fait quelque chose pour que les échecs
soient plus populaires on peut pas
rester sur nos standards habituels où on
peut pas avoir le moindre bruit de
chuchotement soit ça vous dérange pas le
bruit du public bon ils peuvent pas dire
de coup évidemment
et du coup vous mettez juste un casque
anti-bruit ou si ça vous dérange
vraiment vous propose telle solution
pour que vous n'entendez vous entendiez
vraiment autre chose ça en fait je peux
l'entendre avec un public qui est le
droit de s'enthousiasmer faire des trucs
ça te dérange ça te dérange pas mais bon
ça après à toi à toi de voir mais
bon après voir même qu'il faut quand
même faire attention qu'il y ait pas de
de personnes qui puisse souffler les
coûts donc peut-être tu serais obligé
mais en fait pour moi ça c'est un
argument recevable entre guillemets
c'est que tu fais une règle qui est pas
idéale mais parce que tu veux jouer dans
des conditions qui le sont pour pour le
jeu et en fait tu es payé pour ça quand
même
on met de devoir mettre un casque et
d'écouter de la musique parce que le
studio de commentaire est trop proche
au bout d'un moment c'est quand même
particulier
un public de stade de foot aux échecs ça
serait la folie bah nous on l'a fait en
fait ça le truc en fait il y a trois
semaines
on a fait un public de foot dans aux
échecs et on n'a pas eu besoin de casque
pour les joueurs parce qu'on
s'organisait pour que le public soit
assez loin des joueurs bah c'est pas le
même étage ouais bon alors après si les
le public pouvait voir les jours en
direct ça aurait donné encore une autre
émotion et j'aurais pu accepter un
dispositif comme celui-là mais
mais que pour des commentaires ça me
paraît dingue
qui est intéressant là vous D6 enferme
plus ou moins la tour mais les dames je
dois
quelqu'un
me prend des quatre mais là bon ça c'est
une histoire
et là ça et qui va aller au 5 Nice
attention
pas dit je joue pas mal c'est cavaliers
c'est bizarre mais bon c'est très con
quand même je reviens 600 clic que en
fait on regarde un match pendant 8
heures pendant 2 jours et que ça joue
sur B6 au lieu de l'assis ou je sais pas
quoi c'est pas sûr hein c'est pas en soi
le seul truc que je demanderais en fait
et sinon bah pourquoi tu l'as joué quoi
c'était quoi
ça m'intéresse en fait de comprendre
vraiment pas trop perso mais
c'est comme ça ça fait partie du jeu de
toute façon il faut bien jouer du RX ou
Y
oui mais je veux dire c'est
passe un paramètre extérieur aux échecs
en de base c'était c'était plus en 2D
les pièces genre par exemple c'est pas
ça en 3D de base quoi
c'était pas les blancs contre les Noirs
c'était une évolution peut-être des gens
ils préfèrent jouer avec des pièces
grises bon
c'était peut-être mieux ça change en
fait
bon très bien si enfin mais non mais
genre que de base en fait c'était pas
c'était pas les mêmes symboles genre moi
par exemple ça me fait chier de jouer
avec des pièces en 3D très
personnellement même sur un vrai
échiquier
et traditionnellement les pièces sont en
2D
ça pouvait être des petits palais faut
être les deux
ça fait un peu ressembler plus au chaud
qui
a pu avoir
[Musique]
et du coup tu auras une habilité
tu as pas mis ça c'est loin
du couloir mais ça risque rien du mec si
la pousse trop loin elle sort de chier
elle se fait bouffer et sinon il fait un
coup inutile il s'est arrêté avant quoi
c'est pas une pièce en 2drl mais en fait
c'est c'est c'est toujours un genre de
petit palais et puis la pièce elle est
décidée dessus ça a pu exister aussi
donc après
je reparlé que ça ça évolue avec les
échecs asiatiques ça
iques c'est resté comme ça ouais
comme des jetons de dames enfin là et
dessus
ça existe aussi on peut avoir mais c'est
pour ça moi tous les trucs qui sont un
peu des évolutions bon
pourquoi pas en fait mais
la musique
ça me fait chier quoi
ça devient
un immeuble bon bah ok on sera un
immeuble donc peu importe mais
c'est quand même hein
c'est juste que j'aime pas comment dire
c'est ouais après
bon en tout cas il résiste mais ce B6
c'est peut-être pas un mystique en
attendant je n'en sais rien le coup est
bizarre mais en tout cas il a peur
interroge façon d'interview là-dessus
enfin
sont les interviews aussi c'est insipide
là bon tu es une vraie question à poser
sur les loyers de la partie
rien tu pourrais très bien avoir un mode
ou tu dis confirmer le coup ça ça existe
ça existait d'ailleurs
et à toi et libre à toi de le mettre si
tu veux éviter le missclic et ne pas le
mettre tu peux le désactiver quand tu
veux ouais
j'en ai marre de confirmer
ça pourrait être faim c'est pas que ça
pourrait se faire c'est que ça se fait
déjà sur d'autres plateformes
abonnez-vous
je pense contre ça je tenterai si
j'étais pas moi parce que contre moi
j'aurais le lien après mais si je bah
oui c'est normal en fait
il va se [ __ ] dans la merde il va
finir par en perdre une
mais c'est beau c'était tellement un
coup de merde en fait ça peut même
permis un sacrifice de qualité genre
dans l'optique de saut de faire nul
mais tu sais qu'il est capable de la
perdre
d'accord
en fait je comprends que c'est chaud
quoi
la tour bon bah la pâte colonne pour
s'exprimer à fond je sais pas mais bon
je sais pas ce que ça vaut enfin bon la
petite turbinette elle aime bien les
Noirs quoi donc c'est vraiment pas le
service de qualité de l'année mais ça se
tente en pratique après ce qui est beau
c'est que tu as tellement l'impression
que soit il va te reprendre une répète
dès qu'il peut que du coup tu t'énerves
tu t'énerves à un moment donné tu
risques ah maintenant finalement je ne
répète plus je ne viens pas
là ça va là je peux la faire gaffe s'il
a fait B3 l'équivalent du B6 et c'est la
même merde parce que ça donne les cases
noires et tu vas peut-être te faire
retourner
alors dis donne gagnant après la F3 mais
en plus d'un F3 d'un machin je pense
qu'il va le faire c'est tellement dans
le style
non mais en fait il a pas de bols parce
que le coup le plus pleutre est le
meilleur tu te fais changer les dames à
coup sûr en fait voilà tout de suite la
gueule et dégoûté là et le problème
c'est qu'il va c'est tout voilà il va
y arriver
parce qu'en fait d'autres aurait
peut-être hésité quand même avec dames
prends F2 pour prendre un punto mais en
fait
[Musique]
trois c'est pas mal là tu peux vraiment
pas perdre avec les Noirs
c'est dur de te prendre une fourchette
avec le fou qui tient la cassée
mais il a juste fait craquer un car en
fait
une faute de saut quand même face ça me
dégoûte pour Naka qui perd de là-dessus
franchement
non c'est magnifique
c'est très drôle quoi ouais non mais
c'est drôle en fait c'est juste qui te
fait chier à faire que nul et tu dis
pourquoi tu as pas gagné tu fais nul tu
réessayer la partie d'après tu fais là
tu dois dire oui mais je peux quand même
faire ça je tente un peu de toute façon
il va faire nul si jamais il va il va se
jeter sur la moindre nul et en fait il
se met dessus mais là tu sens que tu
prends un risque bien sûr à la cam il
est complètement dégoûté oh c'est
terrible
c'est quand même de l'argent qui
s'envole peut-être
plus de
très très heureux il est tout sourire
je pensais que je voulais faire nul tu
pensais pas que j'allais faire ces
choses là
je pensais que ça c'est tabou
il est écœuré oh le pauvre
il se voit ils sont en face l'un de
l'autre côté
mais tu dois être tellement dégoûté en
plus tu as pas un échec tu as rien quoi
elle est super énervée je crois qu'il a
raté fou F3
va rater c'est un grand mot mais
c'est si pourquoi pas
la chanson très important en fait
quand tu vois le fil de départ tu es
quand même très favori ah bah il est
super favori et c'est le temps à sur
internet il y a le plus d'argent de
l'histoire je crois enfin il y a
absolument personne enfin t'as pas tu as
pas les raisins
tu as plus personne quoi ils sont tous
fait éliminer sur Internet enfin tu es
vraiment très heureux
allez il est complètement dégoûté
bon presque à mon érable
je pense il peut rater
je pense qu'il permet à pas cavalier F3
il y a fougé 4 non je pensais aussi il y
a un piège qui est prend fou prend
tu vas arriver
pas possible bon c'est pas mais bon
c'est quand même la merde
[Musique]
c'est terrible il était à deux doigts de
la sauver
yanish qui a fait nul il est écœurer
elle est très heureux quoi
[Rires]
j'étais provoqué ta tête ta qualité je
t'ai battu
pour faire nul tout le long du truc
ça dégage la racaille ouais ouais ça a
pas dégagé encore la prochaine partie
mais oui
en tout cas
ça doit être tellement dégoûté de perdre
ça ça me rendrait fou quoi je suis fou à
la place de NACA le mec ne fait rien du
tout match
[Musique]
et juste une fois
bah il a rien fait quand même en fait
mais en fait j'ai juste une fois tu
t'énerves un tout petit peu trop en fait
genre le mec c'est l'air tellement quoi
c'est extraordinaire non
mais si j'étais Nakache je serai fou
quoi
je serai fou à sa place
non mais même si c'est je suis pas un
fan de Naka mais là je suis quand même
dégoûté pour lui
enfin c'est horrible de perdre comme ça
c'est vraiment les matchs de tennis de
conasse
il te renvoie que des cloches
tu t'énerves
tu as aucune raison c'est juste tu
t'énerves enfin
je sais même pas pourquoi tu t'énerves
en fait mais tu as envie de le voir
jouer quoi pas juste te remettre là-bas
il reste quand même parti une
ah ouais non c'est horrible pour un cas
je suis un peu deg pour lui
non mais ça doit tu dois pas perdre
comme ça en fait
oui c'est plus Naka qui a perdu son qui
a gagné mais au final
au final ça fait un zéro et balle de
calife
du coup toi aussi tu es un peu deg pour
lui ou non non je m'en fous
c'est notre manière de voir les choses
non mais en fait je veux dire Naka je
peux pas être deck pour lui le nombre de
fois il y a des poubelles et s'accroche
et trou des ressources à la con ou alors
il va flaguer
ouais en fait tu as raison je vais être
très heureux
je m'en fous en fait mais
comme la finale qui a joué 130 cool avec
son cavalier
ça on peut déguster pour ça aussi dans
l'autre sens
[Musique]
c'est pas
ouais c'est vachement bon approche un
peu
ouais il prend pas de risque bon voilà
mais bon bah tu es capable de temps
parler dessus enfin je veux dire
[Musique]
on s'en fout complètement
c'est beau
quand même plus vaillant ouais mais Fab
il a pas tort c'est c'est un des joueurs
les moins fair-play du circuit quand
même
il fait pas des histoires de ouf mais
non tu vois
ouais non mais c'est vrai qu'il est pas
réputé pour être un joueur avec une
excellente conduite quoi
après il a pas le prix du fair-play mais
il pourrait la voir
peut-être bientôt
ça c'est un des joueurs les plus plâtres
c'est pas l'un des joueurs les plus
proches français le joueur le plus
proche parce que ça rime machin avec les
Noirs quand ils s'en vont en l'air je
peux aller essayer de faire quelque
chose il a complètement raté mais il a
essayé en fait ce je me rappelle pas
d'une seule partie où il a essayé en
fait
mais je pense qu'il essaie quasiment
jamais
tu vois si tu l'offres l'opportunité de
faire pourquoi pas il va faire mais de
lui-même
ça m'intéresse pas le style de jeu de
sauter comme si il est quand même elle
fait jamais rien en fait
ouais mais en fait c'est ouais mais même
quand tu donnes la possibilité de
me le donner beaucoup mais
avec un pion avec ses deux cavaliers ou
avec un roi cavalier contre roi de
cavalier pour me faire tomber et que je
perds un truc comme ça
un truc complètement ignoble
je crois qu'il me reste un cavalier
ouais
il m'avait laissé le cavalier en vie
pour me faire tomber
en fait c'est un truc qui ne doit pas
exister parce normalement tu peux
arrêter la pendule après l'arbitre en
fait c'est ça la vraie règle aux échecs
tu profites d'un bug d'Internet tu
taperas d'arrêter dire ok mais c'est nul
et tu flaguer donc ça en fait j'ai
jamais aimé et
faire tomber c'est ça non mais c'était
pas tombé
par tomber parce que là il est à 7
secondes
il a une position mais en fait tu as des
positions qui sont nulles mais genre
d'aide drôle quoi c'est genre ta roi
tour contre trois tours ou des trucs
comme ça mais juste par des sens tu dois
pas jouer en fait donc
non mais là ce qui était vraiment
dégueulasse c'est que
en fait il avait enfin la situation de
la partie fait qu'il avait joué des
mauvais coups pour rentrer là-dedans je
sais pas comment dire en fait c'est mais
bon après il faut mieux jouer aux échecs
pour comprendre
mais juste s'il était moins bien et puis
tu avais une variante normale ou
finalement ça faisait nul oui reste avec
les deux cavaliers Leroy et ouais il
s'était démerdé il avait trouvé un truc
tactique en fait
pour me laisser un cavalier un pion du
coup il m'a pas mangé un pion ce qui met
c'est le cavalier mais
il avait joué complètement à contre sens
pour pour faire ça en fait il pose il
dit tout le monde flag d'ailleurs mais
il y a flag flag en fait je viens de te
dire enfin
tu as des positions tu vois une finale
ou tu as roi tour de pion on 3 tours
pions c'est le tout à l'heure de nakasso
en fait quel lit blanc parce que tu as
une chance de gagner bah tu as quand
même plus mais ok je veux bien en fait
enfin l'autre il est cas ne pas avoir
besoin de moins où je vais plus vite
avant enfin c'est pas le problème mais
quand tu as fou contre fou cavalier ou
tourco contour enfin ça c'est juste nul
mais tu ne joues pas en fait c'est
simple et voilà donc ça non c'est deux
trucs différents et si on peut pas
comprendre c'est que vous n'êtes pas des
genres d'échec en fait je sais pas mais
c'est tout en fait s'il y a pas ces deux
cas très différents et donc le cas qui
avait explique de Naka contre lui bah là
non mais c'était un truc vraiment
c'était un truc vraiment ça la preuve
jamais oublier donc c'est pour te dire à
quel point j'en ai absolument rien à
[ __ ] aussi tu vois
en fait moi je m'en fous complètement
enfin faut que j'en ai rien à [ __ ] en
fait mais on s'en branle en fait
c'est pas normal mais c'est comme ça
enfin après si tout le monde se met à le
faire bah tout le monde va le faire et
puis et puis voilà en fait c'est en fait
il y a eu un vrai tournant dans le dans
le jeu sur Internet moi enfin j'ai
remarqué personnellement c'est le moment
où on a qu'à s'est mis à streamer en
fait
c'est un vrai tournant parce que il y
avait beaucoup moins de jeux sale mais
comme lui il a commencé à jouer ça tout
le temps sur tous ces streams
après elles ont dit bah pourquoi pas moi
pourquoi pas moi
je me suis parce qu'en fait c'est en
fait le problème c'est tout le monde
fait que toi tu fais pas tu es pénalisé
parce que tu vas perdre des points ah
oui ça pendule ouais je vois les
positions ouais ouais pour faire perdre
un maximum de temps avec on s'était
contre ça c'était horrible ça ouais
ouais c'est vrai qu'il a fait c'était le
premier à le faire aussi dans les
speechs ce truc là
bon mais après là il profite d'une règle
enfin oui non mais il a raison c'est pas
beau mais c'est la règle qui mal faite
déjà il est un peu coutumier du fait
pour dire que moi je suis pas dégoûté
mais en même temps je souhaite pas de
mal et si là il en met à gagner bah
bravo pour lui bravo en fait je il peut
se passer ce qui se passe dans le match
peu importe quoi
on est très heureux dans tous les cas
non
surtout si appel à un magasin
quand même guérisseur
[Musique]
en fait il y a une règle quand tu fais
des des raps c'est que tu arrêtes la
pendule tu dis à l'arbitre bon voilà
c'est nul et point final et il peut
rester là regardez montre-moi comment tu
fais nul bon par contre c'est roi fou tu
dis ouais j'ai juste pas me mettre dans
le coin avec le fou à côté pour me
laisser mater donc tu fais juste autre
chose garde en milieu par exemple quoi
pendant 5 6 coups du coup bon il voit
que tu comprends et tu sais faire il dit
bon ok nul
et puis voilà en fait enfin c'est prévu
en fait dans la grande des échecs que tu
dois pas gagner en faisant ça
et donc juste comme sur internet tu peux
pas dire pause j'appelle l'arbitre bah
tu peux jouer le truc dégueulasse il te
laisse faire parce que il y a pas le
choix en fait
parce que tu peux pas faire intervenir
je suis pas un modo qui est 12000 modos
disponible à 24 donc c'est pas un
problème mais en fait par par des sens
tu devrais pas faire le truc qui
interdit à faire en vrai quoi enfin
interdit que tu peux pas faire en vrai
parce que parce que l'autre va faire
l'arbitre
c'est pas le plus fort qui gagne en même
temps il y a quand l'homme qu'on voit le
vrai niveau bah ça je suis pas du tout
d'accord il y a que en partie par
correspondance que tu vas le vrai niveau
pas assez de temps en longue pour voir
le vrai nom
tu vois les mecs les plus forts
franchement là ça me fait rien ça va
il y a aucun travail
qu'est-ce qu'on est dégoûté pour Naka ou
quoi et voilà donc pour discuter en vrai
on a absolument rien à [ __ ] en fait
c'est
jusqu'au discute comme ça pour discuter
c'est faut pas croire que non parce
qu'après les gens ils pensent que bon on
est vraiment là à se dire oui on est
enfin est-ce qu'on dit ou pas est-ce
qu'on va dormir ce soir
une petite larme qui coulera pour la
partie
il faut meubler ouais c'est ça on va
dire en vrai bon
plus intéressant par la finale run
Djokovic demain enfin ce que tu penses
qu'il peut ou par François Australie ce
soir ou je suis beaucoup plus dégoûté
pour l'équipe de France en demi-finale
ce matin
et pour la jouer ce qu'il y a raté je
crois c'est droit qui a raté la pénalité
de la gagne à la dernière minute enfin
là je suis vraiment dégoûté pour elle
là nakasso bon c'est le 45e tournoi qui
joue l'un contre l'autre
ça va pas changer leur vie ni à l'un ni
l'autre enfin je suis au bout d'un
moment là c'est
non mais surtout en plus il y a de la
gagner celle-là on s'en fout enfin il
peut il peut vraiment non mais voilà
enfin après les gens ils pensent que
[Musique]
on débat juste comme ça enfin on débat
même pas en fait on anime
j'ai l'impression à chaque tournoi c'est
fade
c'est un peu parce que
[Musique]
en fait il faudrait des formats des
trucs qui soient un peu plus entraînant
après le truc c'est que oui on est très
dépendant du coup vu que le format là
bon tu vois de ce qui nous propose dans
les parties
bon effectivement wesh là tu vois tu
fais pas trop d'efforts de te mettre le
feu mais en fait on peut pas lui en
vouloir enfin il fait ce qu'il veut
c'est lui il est là pour jouer son match
il est pas là pour faire du spectacle
quoi
il y a un enjeu voilà déjà financier etc
donc il joue ses points et l'eau
il a pas ouvert les vannes pour faire
plaisir au public donc aucun reproche en
fait il gère son match comme il veut
mais du coup bah ouais tu te retrouves
avoir un format ouais bon voilà des
pauses entre les parties des parties qui
en soi bon bah voilà c'est fond de cours
quoi
disons que tu es pas aussi aidé par le
plateau en vrai tu mets des demi
ok enfin tout de suite ça change tout tu
aurais vu en premier tour une bêtise sur
la 45
qui sort Ding Naka qui aurait sorti
enfin j'en sais rien enfin tu m'as
compris quoi
tu es arrivé au demi-tasse sont chauds
bon là tu as un aka saut tu dis oui bon
bah c'est le joueur qui défend le mieux
les positions perdantes contre le joueur
le plus solide bon machin le match un
peu comme ça de l'autre côté tu as un
allié resa Carlson où ça met un peu le
feu aussi opposition de style et tout
d'un coup tu as un beau tournoi mais
tu es aussi quand même très dépendant de
ton plateau
oui bah comme la Bercy en fait un beau
tournoi peut-être
tous les joueurs du top mondial tu fais
des tu fais des qualifications sur Mario
Tennis enfin non mais c'est réellement
ça en fait c'est à Bercy mais tu
qualifie les gens sur Mario Tennis
machin bon d'accord
à un moment donné ton tournoi il est
entre les 7 tu fais 45 minutes de pause
enfin
ça va ça va pas être en ballon non plus
hein
donc tu es quand même très dépendant
mais sur un format un peu un peu
particulier avec un enjeu proche du
néant
tu as besoin d'un beau plateau
ben oui non mais le plateau important
dans tous les cas dans tous les types
oui mais bon par exemple les candidats
avec un plateau comme ça c'est hyper
aussi
parce que si tu gagnes tu vas être
champion tu vas jouer pour le moment
mais du coup a priori si tu voulais
conduire c'est que c'est bon enfin ouais
mais en fait je vais dire que ouais mais
mais sur un tournoi comme ça un peu un
peu plus exhibition on va dire tu as
besoin du gros plateau en fait
sinon c'est effectivement le néant bah
ouais c'est un peu c'est un peu le
problème en soi c'est que tu as besoin
du beau
du beau tableau allez c'est Sarine avec
les Blancs je pense ça croit que ça
turbo dro ou pas du radis on va attendre
la casse
pas de raison
un peu après tu t'es pas obligé de
tomber en l'air mais
ils ont pas eu de bol que
que Ding et une époque qualifie pas en
vrai
et que les vannes se retirent parce
qu'on va déjà tu fais le même tournoi
avec dîner pot
et les Vans
ok Carlson pour vraiment avoir un truc
top mais tu es déjà plus proche de la
vérité quoi
bonding il joue à fond
il a débouché son pion et faire des
concessions en termes de développement
ou quoi mais ouais
[Musique]
c'est pas bête sur ces trois
en fait l'idée
d'accrocher au pion
et sur ces trois C6 tu fais MC2
et tu as ton petit plus quoi ouais c'est
pas grand-chose
[Musique]
une approche voilà tu fais pas énorme
mais
tu sors un peu des sentiers battu et
voilà
en tout cas guéri il a pas l'air
spécialement déstabilisé mais c'est un
truc qui joue
c'est plutôt ouais enfin cool à jouer
avec les Blancs non ça te paraît de
sortir de l'ouverture contre un mec
ultra préparé avec une position
B5 c'est fou français 5 ou c'est quoi
le cavalier tu fais 6 et puis tu es très
heureux quoi ah bah si tu te retrouves
dans ça tu es très bien mais oui donc
c'est français
c'est juste pour avoir un peu le cœur
net de ce que ça donnait parce que
mais bon
je me demande en fait je pense guérit il
connaît
ouais c'est sûr
après enfin c'est
pas de l'impro quoi et puis bon il a
dépensé 25 secondes on est au 9e coup et
la position enfin tu pourrais déjà
perdre oui
donc oui il connaît en fait des guéris
oui bah tu vois lui il fait ses petites
révisions chaque jour peut-être pour te
connaître ça
il te joue la structure dont on parlait
dans des vidéos ce truc là
tu feras de 5 prendre le centre machin
bon tu as pas le fou de la Catalane bon
s'il y a vraiment besoin il pourra aller
faire un tour sur cette diagonale
mais ouais beaucoup de c'est bien ça
joue de part et d'autre ils font pas
peut-être sur Annuler à la fin mais
après combat
après gros combat
il a pas l'air bien le H ouais bah avec
les noirs pour battre ça c'est pas
facile après ça il peut être avoir un
excès de clôture en fait
de prendre 200000 dollars quand même
un mine de rien c'est quand même un gros
prix
d'habitude il crache pas
sur l'argent quoi donc s'il peut revenir
aller chercher ses 200000 il sera 13h
il aurait raison
ça va repartir je pense mais ça va être
une partie intéressante de façon on les
reverra l'Armageddon probablement
pas le truc c'est qu'on doit faire un
choix on peut pas tout regarder en même
temps mais vu qu'on a plus regardé
l'autre match et que bah ça joue la
calife c'est vrai qu'on peut pas laisser
passer ce sauna cam mais c'est match
intéressant aussi en fait ce guérit
Sarine c'est juste bah c'est une moins
belle affiche donc c'est normal j'ai
envie de dire mais ok
ça joue et voilà regarde
petite nul aurait fait plaisir quand
même
prédis c'est un caste pas forcément une
question d'argent ou enfin 200000 je
pense d'un gars il crache pas dessus
non mais en fait
disons il y a pas un prestige de ouf a
gagné
le Tour enfin
ouais mais c'est le droit le plus doté
de l'année donc voilà du coup
Palma j'ai gagné global
parce que là je crois qu'il prend que 80
quoi donc à 120 000 balles de plus aller
chercher pour pour gagner 3 parties
enfin c'est quand même beaucoup d'argent
enfin c'est pas la peine de dire qu'il
est dépendant il est pas dépendant de ce
dessin décembre mais je pense que pour
lui 120 000 dollars c'est quelque chose
d'important enfin il a envie de les
gagner quoi bah c'est pas pilote ah
voilà c'est ça en fait c'est pas parce
que tu es plus riche que l'argent est
moins important pour toi enfin je sais
pas comment dire
s'il y a des gens tu sens que ils ont
envie de
gagner quoi il a envie de prendre ses
200 villes enfin laisse-le prendre ces
200 vis il a envie il fallait être très
heureux
si la plus de 50 millions c'est
justement que il aime bien prendre les
100000 par 6 par là c'est un truc très
bête ah oui mais il n'a pas il n'aime
pas l'argent parce qu'il a déjà beaucoup
bah en fait c'est peut-être l'inverse en
fait c'est peut-être parce qu'il aime
tellement l'argent qu'il en a autant
enfin je sais pas comment dire c'est
j'arrive pas trop à comprendre la
logique
moi ça me paraît logique en fait
et d'ailleurs bon je pense pas qu'il est
50 millions
de vidéos qu'il a fait quand il y avait
une image pour faire du buzz et pour se
faire du fric sur cette histoire là faut
vraiment aimer le fric pour le faire
enfin et tant mieux enfin il a raison
chacun aime ce qu'il veut enfin je vois
pas pourquoi ce serait un défaut
mais je pense ça le fait chier de perdre
120 000 balles contre un mec il est plus
fort enfin c'est parce que la finale
dirige ou Sarine je pense c'est vraiment
facile ouais pour un tel et il doit se
sentir plus fort
je suis gros favori et que c'est de ma
faute en fait c'est moi qui passe à côté
les cupidité c'est effectivement un
défaut ça dépend de ton référentiel en
fait enfin c'est laisse les gens s'il a
envie d'être cupide il est cuits mal en
fait
d'aimer l'argent facilement l'argent il
aime l'argent enfin tant mieux pour lui
j'aurais plutôt penser à ça pour la
gloire du titre comme dirait surtout
chacun se bat pour ce qu'il n'a pas oui
mais il fait il n'a pas de gloire ce
titre en fait
le problème
c'est en fait les candidats genre je
pense que il échange 10 victoires de
tournoi 200000 pour gagner les candidats
ça j'en suis sûr à 100%
il avait oublié de mettre ses écouteurs
on lui a fait une remontrance terrible
une sorte d'estomac
mais oui par contre il pourrait échanger
même pas mal d'argent pour les candidat
mais oui bien sûr enfin c'est pour ça
que j'ai en fait ce titre là en soi il
te dit ben ouais je le gagne 10 fois en
fait 10 victoires comme ça si je donne
mon prix je gagne les candidats bon il
te donnerait les 10 millions mais genre
là en fait c'est toi tu le joues pour
l'argent en fait donc ça il a il a
dépensé son temps pour gagner le truc
machin enfin déjà il est sportif
professionnel et il peut gagner 200000
ce qui a un prix énorme pour un temps à
d'échec c'est plus que les grandes
chasse tours Jack il s'est qui envoyait
tous les grands de chez soi et tout il a
pris 250 000 pour gagner une série de
tournois giga difficile
et où tu joues pas une semaine enfin tu
joues trois fois trois semaines trois
semaines trois fois 11 jours mais tu as
plus de droite à gauche et puis en terme
de préparation c'est plus dur enfin bon
c'est un toi qui est mille fois plus dur
les adversaires sont plus forts et là
pour un tournoi qui dure six jours tu as
quasiment autant pris pour gagner un
Grand chaise tour et en gros Douda qui
pourrait être un adversaire fort bon bah
le match il se passe très bien parce
qu'il tilt et il te le donne entre
guillemets
est un match dure c'est celui-là
vraiment enfin si tu regardes le truc
c'est le match vraiment qui va être le
plus dur pour toi et tu sens que ça il
est en forme et qui joue bien quand même
et tu dis [ __ ] je m'en vais en l'air
tout seul et
enfin moi je comprends qu'il soit énervé
en fait je vois pas pourquoi les gens
ils veulent c'est normal enfin
[Musique]
puis là bah du coup je ressens des
années il joue pour revenir mais saut du
coup peut-être pas le meilleur choix
quoi de laisser cette année
je sentais mieux que 4 en fait
de Dubaï au tennis de t'assurer énorme
pour un si petit tournoi du coup
palmarès à 8 x 20h 5 fois de Djokovic
bah ouais mais c'est ça en fait et c'est
sûr que ça te fait chier genre c'est
comme si il fait des rêves en fait il y
a que des plots dans le tournoi et en
demi-finale hyper contre Marine silitch
pas cher c'est pas facile si les
chabattre dire ça te fait quand même
chier
que tu vas 9 ans normalement enfin
enfin que tu dis que tu vas à la fin
normalement pas 9 fois sur 10
oui le bâtard c'est souvent mais c'est
vrai qu'il a perdu une fois
important à demi de l'US Open 2014
mais sinon il est très bon
là c'est pareil sur la physionomie du
match si tu es Naka sur toutes les
sportifs surestiment toujours parce que
c'est juste bien de le faire et ils sont
comme ça ils ont raison d'être comme ça
on a qu'à c'est sûr qu'ici ok un tel
comme sauf je perds tout seul enfin il
doit se dire je pouvais pas perdre une
partie sans trop abuser en fait
de la partie d'après c'est énervant
d'ailleurs
et il arrivait à faire nul sur le match
mais il aurait perdu la onzième en
faisant ça
marche quoi
bon il a pas voulu rentrer dans
surprendre si on prend le G4 6 il fait
ça
fait mal quand même [ __ ] il y avait de
le faire c'est logique en fait je sais
pas comment dire il est pleutre mais
contrairement faut jouer des coups parce
que de toute façon tu vois que c'est
bien il va faire et puis en plus si tu
fais pas en fait c'est encore pire le
cavalier va rebondir enfin tu fais trois
tu l'envoies en H6 tu lui fais G4 c'est
hyper logique tu as le fou qui va partir
en G2 tu as fout trois dames des deux
grands rock
bon évidemment de base tu veux pas rock
opposé mais celui-là il est quand même
magnifique
comme ça tu en joues tous les jours même
dans un dans une partie tu dois faire
nul enfin
tu joues et puis si tu es mieux tu es
mieux en fait
il va le faire
[Musique]
E5 avant non pour essayer de forcer un
peu les choses
et puis là tu fais KFC
même il est énervé on t'es énervé tu es
un peu moins lucide là tu cliques on
sent que la critiquerai de s'écoule
après bon
pareil ça peut pas faire nul nul en
étant tout symétrique enfin tu es
moins bien voilà et si ça joue bien il
va gagner cette partie
au moins de pas la perdre il va
peut-être trouver un moyen de forcer
nullement mais mais ça force à jouer
c'est pas là en train de jouer un truc
tous ces métrique une berlinoise tous
ces change ou je sais pas quoi
ça fait un peu le taf
tu le fais jouer quoi complètement
donc j'ai pas vraiment de critique sur
cette approche là
il est obligé mais c'est joli quand même
là ce qu'il vient de faire avec le
cheval
carrousel quoi en plus tu peux revenir
en F6 tu peux bien redessiner rien ça
redessine pas
faudrait que tu puisses revenir en ce
sens là
ah c'est très beau
en fait tu fasses ça de manière infinie
c'est assez beau quand même
se fait aussi un truc infini et te
réclame la trois fois même position quoi
tu préfères quoi d'infini de jolis
est-ce que tu pourrais se faire ça ça ça
ça
aussi tu fais un
même chose la même chose de l'autre côté
était très heureux et tout le monde est
heureux et tout on dit oui très belle
partie magnifique nous avons jamais vu
ça
c'était très artistique
et peut-être qu'ils pourront nous faire
des toiles à partir des mouvements de
pièces ou tu as des flèches de toutes
les pièces qui a faim sont représentés
dans un carré ou même mais ils ont fait
ça néfaste les cases mais ça a été fait
mais champions de souris font ça ils
font ils le vent même en NFT après hein
ouais ouais après tu peux l'acheter
en NFT après c'est le NFC des parties tu
as les couilles qui se dessine ça te
fait un dessin et c'est ton dessin en
NFT
ça a été devancé par cette idée de génie
merde quelque chose
bah ouais mais ça te permet d'acheter
des NFC Fab c'est le futur le NFT de
toute façon
je suis pas très au fait de ces trucs je
sais pas
peut-être
pas je sais pas
contente mais bon là faut pas trop
regarder la jauge j'en sais partie
parce que c'est pas une partie
jaugeesque mais je crois qu'il Carole et
il en Full Tilt mais je vous dis en fait
que ça le fait chier les gens me croient
pas c'est terrible dans le chat toi il
s'en fout machin et tout je lui dise
pourquoi il est très énervé non machin
tu dis de la merde bon bah tu regardes
la partie il se trouve que j'ai raison
mais c'est que ça fait combien de fois
en fait qu'on a raison et que tout le
monde nous chie dessus Fab
ouais non oui enfin non mais il est
énervé en fait oui c'est con la foule 4
il y avait un truc qui tue
pour
Pessac
c'était fini tout de suite c'était pas
très dur non
c'était hyper facilement on peut montrer
c'est vraiment très simple mais bon faut
jouer vraiment le gain quoi c'est ça le
problème donc F3 et double attaque B7
c'était le coup qui gêne évidemment et
là aussi puis on prend
les deux sont bien
c'est logique avec la lame prend le fou
par échec
tu prends pas ça peut la merde quand
même quoi tu vas attaquer le cavalier
[Musique]
ou puis on prend roi fit pion prend tu
prends du roi
qui a eu c'était terminé ouais la partie
bon qui a fait un truc logique ça va
être toujours très bien
mais bon de laisser la bête blessée en
vie attention et surtout que si d'un cas
la vue je sais pas moi j'ai toujours un
truc quand je vois quelqu'un atteint un
gain assez évident je vais y aller faut
s'accrocher cette rumeur en sel
le problème c'est quand même bien foutu
encore
ah ouais mais c'est dur en fait
il y a déjà eu dans la partie de
guérisseur
si la partie là se termine vite ah oui
oui encore
à mon avis aussi
ouais très heureux
on va passer un tellement beau weekend
si c'est ça qui gagne et guérit qui
gagne de l'autre côté
en fait c'est beau ils vont complètement
se faire poser le tournoi va être suer
en fait
ça va être beau
en plus je pense que même s'ils veulent
faire différemment ils peuvent pas
je vais guérir même si vous voulez jouer
le gain à fond et tout genre c'est
tellement contre nature que celui qui le
forme qui revient au galop quoi ouais
viens en fait je pense que ça te fait
perdre le match instantanément enfin je
pense qu'ils peuvent pas enfin tu vas
trop à l'encontre de ton style naturel
non non mais tu dois être fidèle à
toi-même il y a pas de problème bon
voilà tourner les deux ça a l'air
logique et fort non je pense sur les
deux dames C8 et C5 non mais bon tu vas
te prendre même B4 tu as même
tellement pas comme il est revenu à une
et tu t'es fait tourner la colonne des
quoi donc c'est c'est une ruse
malheureusement
enfin l'ordinateur il propose quand même
[Musique]
c'est magnifique
je prends une photo revend là ça
et que en fait magnifique truc c'est lui
tout seul qui l'a créé
le coup de peinture
est-ce que tu penses que ce il cherche à
faire nul là
bah oui Non Non mais si l'envoyer il
saute dessus
pour un peu même dans mes fins
normal c'est le seul qui fait pas grand
chose tu l'amènes vers les belles gaz
d'avoir un trou du B4
je pense que c'est un ratat pour un
joueur du niveau de saut
ben nous on se fera encore arnaquer mais
je sais pas trop dans quel état il y en
a qu'un
il a l'air hyper énervé
il a envie de gagner mais que dans un
état qu'il a pas le
mais il était il est revenu très tôt à
la partie enfin je crois qu'il était
vraiment écœuré de la partie précédente
c'est vraiment un tournoi qui lui
tendait les bras en fait
non mais en fait il est dégoûté
mais bon il est peut-être quand même à
l'affût de la connerie mais moins que en
temps normal
c'est sûr mais bon c'est tellement foutu
dans la merde enfin je sais pas comment
il s'est foutu cette opposition tout
seul là c'est fou quoi
mais ça c'est incroyable même là tu sens
ça pleutreitude extrême
alors je pense qu'un fil rouge à très
déjà en train de t'enchaîner
tactiquement pour se terminer
ça qui aurait été bien blindé mais
maintenant que tu bouffes le caillot 7
il reprend un peu du poil de la bête là
un peu la merde je suis un peu dégoûté
mais peut-être Jarnac
mais ça c'est sûr qu'il est gigas
stressé
il se cache derrière
quand même
ouais
ça doit être tellement dur d'être genre
professionnel quand c'est comme ça c'est
incontrôlable en plus tu peux rien y
faire
il le sait en plus c'est terrible
[Musique]
regarde il est très heureux B5 AB il va
te faire foudre
il a l'air très heureux là je pense
qu'il va faire foudre puis on prend tout
reprend qui est assez simple il doit
dire parce que
il devrait déjà penser évacuer le sien
quoi faire là-bas
il échange juste tout en fait ça ici il
va tout prendre j'avais vu en fait
honnêtement c'est si j'étais sur Kiss
c'est exactement la même idée mais je
m'étais dit ça tu peux te faire arnaquer
quand même mais remarque non roi C2 qui
est des trois tu prends oh le malaise
[ __ ] il joue vraiment la nuit à fond
hein
c'est vraiment un malade mais tu sais
qu'il est capable de la perdre
non mais attends il va perdre ça
et je sais pas bon après normalement
super pas mais bon les pièces bougent
quoi
il est un peu comme un con
j'ai jamais vu ça c'est imposé comment
tu veux jouer aux échecs en fait
il va réellement perdre ça
il le sait en plus qui va la gagner
regarde
c'est hallucinant ce qu'il a fait Wesley
c'est incroyable d'avoir autant peur en
fait
voilà elle est quand même du rap à
perdre
c'est la crise parce que la finale fou
contre cavaliers elle est peut-être dur
à défendre
beaucoup de pions sur blanc
des fous le 5
peuvent être quand même
j'ai peur pour lui que tu reprends dans
F3 cavalier E6 vous prend aussi
vraiment trop facile
t'auras jamais d'attaque de match sur le
roi avec les Noirs non et ça je pense
c'est trop facile de faire nul par
contre j'ai réussi à garder toutes les
pièces ah ça y est il a vu fou prend le
5 salut il a été heureux elle va faire
un petit coup de tête
vous prend des cinq fouet 4 3D de
prend on reprend
non mais c'est incroyable ce qu'il fait
ouais c'est pourquoi tu fais ça en fait
mais t'imagines à quel point ça doit
être dur pour lui de jouer aux échec
Wesley parce que ça s'explique que par
la peur en fait oui et du coup ça veut
dire que c'est pas confortable pour lui
de jouer il doit pas se sentir bien en
fait pour jouer comme ça ben non
et du coup ça a vraiment une souffrance
pour lui de jouer
ok peut-être qu'il fasse froisser deux
tours E5 tu reprends C4 3 B1
[Musique]
qui écrivent dans le chat il me fait de
la peine en vrai c'est triste enfin
c'est triste
pas
c'est comme ça enfin dire si il a trop
du mal à jouer bah oui c'est triste en
fait mais c'est aux échecs en fait juste
toi que tu fais un truc tous les jours
de ta vie que tu aimes fondamentalement
pas quoi
la tête qui aime bien les échecs mais
que la tension compétition ne peut pas
parce que là c'est que psychologique
fait c'est pas parce qu'il a ce qu'il a
joué c'est impossible
c'est une position c'est même pas que
c'est gagnant c'est que il gagne enfin
sans pression il gagne les yeux fermés
en belette en fait
jamais hyper ça enfin ça dépend si tu
mets cette position de base tu dis
peut-être ça mais si tu vois d'où ça
vient ah non mais il peut peur enfin non
mais à mon avis
toi tu as trop de pièces enfin tu as
trois pièces qui t'attaque quoi c'est
chiant tu as aucune prise sur les cases
noires c'est pas vous mettre les pièces
il y a des fourchettes il y a le il y a
la pendule
mais il aurait peut-être dû jouer la
finale faucon de cavalier
[Rires]
comment tu peux perdre ça
non mais j'espère qu'il va gagner ce
quand même c'est trop
c'est trop de perdre ça
non mais c'est pas comme
unique c'est une partie c'est un titre
de champion du monde et
il est pas gagnant en fait
la sauce est récurrent c'est juste un
mal-être profond
c'est il faut comparer ce qui est
comparable
tout le temps et quel que soit l'enjeu
là c'est comme on a dit c'est pas un
enjeu de ouf c'est financier mais c'est
pas autre chose
d'ajouter ça à ton palmarès c'est pas
qui est champion du monde tu marques
l'histoire des échecs c'est-à-dire que
moi je peux te les réciter les mecs donc
des matchs qui commençaient à avoir lieu
en 1886 et ok on connaît toujours plus
de 150 ans plus tard donc tu rentres
vraiment dans l'histoire des échecs le
Global bon tu deviens tu viens pas on
s'en fout en fait
donc oui c'est une pression spéciale moi
je dois championnat du monde très
spécial
et donc le fait que sauce soit aussi
stressé pour un truc aussi insignifiant
c'est que ouais juste c'est un mal-être
c'est un truc super mal avec avec les
échecs et c'est triste parce que c'est
pas l'histoire niveau de jeu c'est
complètement autre chose
on est dans les rationnels
psychologique et voilà mais là je vois
pas comment ils s'en sort en fait dans
cette partie là il s'est mis dans un tel
état il était tellement gagnant c'était
simple c'était hyper facile
de défense en fait il veut essayer de
sacrifier la dame maintenant contre les
deux pièces
sur la cam
mais il s'est bien repris quand même
enfin il a pas que non perdu pied à se
prendre une fourchette tempo parce que
c'était parti pour en fait
c'était chaque coup une connerie et ça
descendait la vitesse grand V là en fait
maintenant il s'enregistre il défend
quoi
si réussi à faire F3 ou des 5 x 4
allez fais peut-être d'un F3 non
[Musique]
il y a pas de menace mais tu bloques
après c'est aussi pour ça qu'il est top
mondial c'est qu'il est capable même en
étant en train de perdre pied de de
fermer la porte
[Musique]
pour aller vers B4 TD4 c'est cavaliers
aussi tu le bouffes c'est cavalier
assiste tu le bouffes
donc il a mis un setup où il se fait pas
toucher facilement
son point fort entre guillemets
mais il suit il a les mains moites
sans qu'il est pas loin là
faire nul son point fort ultime mais
c'est pour ça que le match contre guéri
ça peut promettre
guérisse à peu près
[Musique]
ça peut être extraordinaire
non mais en fait je comprends qu'il est
tout le temps fermé
[Musique]
j'aurais vraiment du mal à sa place
mais là ça va beaucoup mieux qu'il y a
quelques coups c'est quand même le les
pièces qui étaient chiantes
là on voit pas de menaces noires
immédiatement en tout cas
assez vite pour se garder du temps
mais c'est juste après c'est juste après
ouais
c'est juste après
on va voir si ça
mais après peut-être qu'il s'est dit que
si le laisse tourner pendant des plombes
comme décision parce que c'est vrai que
ce pion F c'était ce pion G5 c'était
plus une prise dans la position des
noirs
par là-bas
un moment donné je sais pas si tu prends
un tour de échecs il fait roi des uns et
peut-être que tu as un peu moins en
danger à l'endroit aussi
il est un peu enlevé de la case F4
non mais en fait je sais pas mieux saut
de savoir comment il doit plus que faire
nul les défenses
il va quand même se prendre une couille
ah c'est sûr c'est trop dur à défendre
bien jouer à
je pense qu'il veut se changer le set up
et se mettre le fond des trois
des clous de toute façon
mais je pense qu'il vaut vraiment
repartir avec le roi vers eux il en a
marre quoi
ok
[Musique]
ça fait du bien hein
tu es obligé non
Kevin et tant pis
il est encore tourné 6
un roi ici ça va encore
peut-être dans ma vie
petit à petit là
c'était malin tour des six [ __ ] un peu
la merde faire perdre du temps
franchement c'est
chaud
j'ai 5
et sur Full prend H4 tu prends
ne mange pas pourquoi il a voulu filer
H5 mais bon c'était un peu bizarre c'est
un peu dur à trouver il est en train de
choque je suis parti
de tourner encore Fab
et ben voilà une partie sympa avec un
peu de pression
il est sous pression là ouais
qui fait le taf
il a plus que 17 secondes le joueur
américain
enfin ces deux Américains la veille en
un des deux qui a plus 18 secondes
et ce qui suit et ce qui suit pas parce
que de l'autre côté il a quand même
liquidé une aile
et il y a peut-être moins de réseau de
maths mais j'en sais rien Fab non il y a
moins de maths
mais bon on a cassé
dame j'ai 8 3e c'est pas si simple
encore attention Wesley
c'est chaud cette seconde et n'a qu'à
concentré comme Jaja
il y a quand même 200000 balles aller
chercher
un échec
grand comme une maison la gaffe est où
il perd au dernier moment et il se fait
défoncer dans leur magasin c'est quand
même gros comme une maison a priori
c'est le scénario mais bon sticks
on a qu'à se remis en place oh c'est
terrible
quelle idée d'être allé donner ce pion h
quand même
voilà c'est dur là
il va pas trouver le coup 3 secondes une
il va pas y arriver fabuleux
viens jouer fou aussi tellement un coup
d'enflure mais très bien joué parce que
ça empêche les échecs
il repère encore le pur à 4
ah c'est terrible il s'est fait bouffer
il fait quand même un gros taf pour pour
pas se prendre de fourchette
toujours se mettre en diagonale face à
un cavalier quand on a peu de temps
qu'est-ce que c'est dur
ce qui peut bouffer le piano et torcer 5
il a dû regarder
qu'est-ce que c'est dur favrois de
fourchette encore peut-être
non il a raté fu F7 d'un F2 mais en fait
il joue aucun coup pour gagner Wesley
mais il les voit pas oui mais il cherche
même pas je pense
là quand même et fousser 6
et c'est gagné pour Wesley
oh oui il est dégoûté
ah c'est terrible il est écœuré éliminé
éliminer Fab ah ok bon c'est cool pour
Wesley quoi qui finit quand même par
emporter cette partie
malgré lui mais c'est beau c'est bien
sûr saisir c'est bien
oh le dame C4 échec quand il a vu de va
être content ouais
oh là là mais c'était c'est incroyable
qu'il ait défendu quand même qu'elle
défense ça semblait vraiment impossible
[Musique]
c'est un des seuls joueurs au monde qui
pouvait défendre cette position vu le
scénario de la partie je pense
j'ai même pas sûr bizarre par lui et
cariakine je vois pas qui d'autre
pourrait défendre ça en fait au monde
enfin genre même Carlson dans un tel
scénario il en peut généralement
mais quelle défense
avant l'armée
allez on fait la petite pause avant
l'Armageddon
téléphone avec moi comme ça j'aurai la
pendule
dans 10 minutes
[Musique]
allez ça repart
on repart les amis avec Annie gigari
on a deux caméras sur guéri là
c'est reparti en avance cette fois-ci
on pouvait pas s'attendre ça
repart toujours en retard
avec le B6 et compagnie
il rejoue il rejoue il
rejointes je suis un peu on est un peu
pris de courant pourquoi ça reprend en
avance tout d'un coup
je comprendrais jamais en fait
bon en tout cas il a pris les noirs et
qui a dû prendre 13 minutes exactement
magnifique je me dis que franchement moi
je veux bien même 10 minutes
donc ça peut être
pas être trompeur donc le coup d'envoi
de rugby est parti
on est sur l'Armageddon quand même mais
il est peut-être pas mal là non genre tu
prends tu fais fou F6 tu tapes partout
après je dis ça
tu dis rien mais en réalité j'en sais
rien
mais bon
on va à l'impact
premier mot le porter quoi
important les premiers mots le portés
Fab pour mettre de l'impact physique
directement
c'est qu'à l'époque à l'époque du rugby
à l'ancienne tu avais des joueurs ils
partaient
en fait leur plaisir au coup d'endroit
c'est les piliers ou quoi c'était que tu
remettes des ballons pas trop loin pour
courir à fond et genre le pilier il
arrive pas
mais bon tu peux poser chaque pas trop
le faire mais ce serait beau en fait tu
arrives l'écran
tu défonces en fait dès le premier coup
quoi tu l'impact quoi touche pas à ça
il veut faire fout à 4 qui a essayé 4
ça arrive de partout peut-être à quoi
trop avec les Blancs
peut-être
mais peut-être fou B5
et tu viens lui taper le pion parce que
tu t'attaqueras eux deux on va on se
dirige peut-être vers la finale de rêve
hein femme nous je pense qu'on est par
là-dessus on est d'accord on est team
guéri tous les deux
avec les Noirs
petite nul
il avait ah mais Raja bof avait
abandonné la dernière fois il aurait dû
proposer nul ça aurait été accepté
allez allez
qu'on appelle aussi
le gastronome en culotte courte
se faire guérir on verra bien guérira le
dernier et ce sera probablement à Nice
oh bah là on est très heureux
on nage dans le bonheur avec Fab notre
chouchou notre poulain on va avoir notre
finale de rêve la fiche
ça va être une affiche de folie
cavalière à
37 Damas 8 allez on va aller taper
là-dessus peut-être même tout racisme
peut-être
allez il faut y aller il faut y aller
allez à Nice
il va nous chercher cette finale ah nous
on serait super nous on serait des
supporters d'anishafont on aurait les
banderoles
ce serait beau d'aller avec le tifo
Guiri quoi
on ferait un chalala ah les guiris
[Musique]
on aurait les écharpes on tourne arrêt
orange en plus mais c'est vrai je suis
au départ invité à Toronto en fait non
on aurait gueulé comme ils peuvent pas
entendre et gueuler comme des malades
pendant des heures en fait
peut-être qu'on serait quand même passé
au travers des casques
et on aurait pu dire les bravo et carou
pour les 80 000 balles
[Rires]
c'est sûr
en plus il a un fond vert avec lui
il a le fond vert
supporter de la SS c'est sûr magnifique
il bloque tout à niche oh ça suit côté
NiAl bah oui lui il a un fond de merde
en fait derrière lui il est une Berg je
sais pas quoi il est important quand
même le sponsor de famille
important mais il a pas le fond vert
il a pas le fond vert
icalité pour les Australiens ouais mais
bon je tiens au courant t'inquiète pas
ça
comme disent
les Américains les Américains
inquiète toi pour Aniche Fab
ça serait dommage de voir une finale
sarenzo quand même on est à un pas de la
finale de rêve
ce serait tellement
bah tu vois si proche du but quoi
oui
ce serait la déception pour de mon côté
mais il a l'air de suer il est de moins
en moins bien au temps plus cuit de 55
allez à Nice il faut se réveiller faut
envoyer les coups mais là le Dame des 7
est un peu faiblard quand même
oh il est en train de tuer
voilà qui a l'air très heureux
en mode détente là complètement
ça c'est le beau jeu ça c'est la niche
qu'on aime
mais attends
cavalier F3 fou prendre fou prends C3
oh pourquoi pas
non c'est de la merde en fait
non non ça passe pas
il veut quoi en fait il faut prendre
trois fou prend et tout reprend C3
possible mais à ce niveau de jeu FAP ça
peut trouver
et ces quatre partout pour le moment
shiny chez
ignal
moi je pense que ce match de rugby a
passé de d'entractes il y a une pénalité
il y a une minute tu me dis qu'il y a de
nouveau pénalités c'est problématique
Fab oui il faut l'engagement direct
c'est complexe rentre un peu au
vestiaire
alors on donne quoi le temps fable 8 28
contre
attention quand même à l'excès de
clôture
bah ouais c'est pour ça que j'ai
attention quand même non mais trois
c'est vraiment
[Musique]
vraiment difficile
aurait pu trouver
ne sous-estime pas Fab la puissance de
guérir
allez il se place
pas notre douche
à faire je sais pas j'ai une bêtise mais
eux trois fois
il consolide Dame des deux et un jour
c'est 4 c'est terminé
il y est pas encore
jour indien voyez un peu dans la merde
quand même parce que
ok l'ordi
fous des quatre parce que sur Full prend
des quatre si on prend des quatre tu as
pas trop vite ok bon c'est très gentil
hein
tu peux mais en fait il va pas faire
bon sport
en fait le truc
ça dépend si tu as déjà vu le thème
là comme ça non on trouve pas tu la
force moi j'ai déjà vu des trucs pareils
en regardant les parties les bilans de
parties à l'analyse et tout mais bon
de là elle trouvait là maintenant
[Musique]
ça me paraît impossible Fab
non
boum boum BK
[Musique]
c'est vraiment dur à trouver là
ce qui a trouvé c'est vraiment dur
très franchement faut trop à Tours c'est
vite fou des 4
ouais
il a fait le coup normal
en fait la question bon c'est clair mais
tu prends quoi c'est ça je sais pas
tu me poses une colle en B2
la tour aussi
je sais pas trop ça dépend si j'arrive à
[ __ ] le truc [ __ ] une tour en A3 et
le foncer 4
couilles en fait
[Musique]
en B2 à la fin en fait le plan roi F1
roi machin roi B1 tours B2 il fait hyper
mal
tu vois même dans le scénario tu changes
tout tu restes avec le pion des 4 tu as
le pion à deux il te reste une tour
chacun la tour en B2 et tu vas ramenera
jusqu'en B1 quand même non
mais bon
il faut leur éviter quand même une fois
que j'ai le droit après ça avance tout
seul
bon si je la dame ok absolument tout ça
va jouer au tempo c'est le temps de
faire G5 H5 H4 mais bon
au 3 je ferai presque j'ai 5 ans
j'ai 6 je considère même pas
tout de suite je pense
vraiment de toute façon tu allais mettre
du couloir qui doivent te gêner dans
1000 variante ouais j'ai 5 c'était sûr
normal je sais bien jouer mais c'est ce
qu'on pense et bonne soirée
les deux coups de fou
c'est peut-être pas si grave
non je suis pas trop mais bon c'est vrai
qu'il faut
un moment il est obligé de se bouger un
peu et je veux des coups
avec les Noirs contre 8
ça va mais bon
tu peux pas te mettre trop mal parce que
tu peux pas te mettre trop mal ouais
mais après tu peux dire que la finale de
tour à la fin elle sera pas trop dur à
jouer si tu réussis à stabiliser
j'en suis réussi à faire tour à trois
tours B2 là bon ça devrait aller après
exactement ouais
ce qu'on peut faire tourner à 3
tu vas en B3
ok peut-être ça peut-être ça va pas mais
on commence à faire des trucs un peu
incertain quoi on peut trouver dans un
sac contre 4 à la fin ça fait pas des
trucs aussi simple que ce qu'on veut
profiter de H5 pour flash 5 je vais te
dire peut-être des fois je sens qu'il
va faire [ __ ] G6
c'est un autre des défauts tu auras fait
tomber de ce que tu pourras la même en
faisant fout ces deux positions
quoi que bon il fera à 4 tu ferais tout
à 5 et je suis un peu inquiet pour aller
pourtant il trouve les coups mais
ça consomme du temps
c'est le problème
c'est exactement ce qu'on veut pas pour
notre chouchou
c'est exactement ce qu'on veut éviter
pour notre chouchou
[Musique]
vas-y
4 ça donne l'option de faire prise et je
veux la cinquième rangée mais ça doit
aller
exactement je suis d'accord
on l'a voulu on l'a eu
les Bleus à 5 m de la ligne
il y a une belle action peut-être pour
le 15 de France mais
peut-être une pause là pour le 15 de
France enfin peut-être vous faire faut
introduire la pause
et tu reviens juste action dans une
demi-heure
je crois qu'ils ont les
et au final de tour à 54
je sais pas
en tout cas tu as plus de chance que
quatre contrats etc
peut-être qu'il joue un peu vite là NiAl
ouais en fait je me pose une question au
tout début il pouvait pas essayer de
faire un 4 pour péter la structure et
avoir
hyper technique hyper compliqué ou tu
dois choisir un set up
à ce moment-là déjà pour Sarine c'est un
peu trop quand même
et pour en revenir sur des histoires de
Flag si ça arrive là je pourrai faire
flaguer c'est normal
c'est pas le fourgon de fou
avantage autant tu dois jouer pour et il
a une position il entend de plus et puis
là je vais longtemps il y a là il y a
rien à dire mais ça il va pas la gagner
par contre c'est plus en plus simple
mais bon c'est trop de comment ça a joué
la montre quand même
oui c'est beaucoup trop tôt pour
démarrer ce jeu là
F4 c'est pas si c'est clair
il peut être bien
il peut être bien encore
[Musique]
en se laissant clouer sur la 6e
étais pas obligé de commencer à jouer
vite si tôt non plus je sais pas c'est
bizarre
toute cette phase de la partie bizarre
mais ça je crois que c'est encore nul ça
ressemble à la finale un peu de ma média
Rohff firugarce pas tout à fait la même
sur les mêmes idées mais tu peux les
perdre mais tu peux les perdre
en fait ce serait l'option E4 et ce sera
ce serait nul très facilement avec le
pion G4
après tu peux tu peux te faire Contrex
si le roi rentre en G5 ou quoi
enfin
peu importe mon Fab
c'est comme ça
et c'est l'équipe de France qui prend un
essai
mais c'était très haut sur le terrain
ils sont prêts
généralement c'est ce qu'ils font un
fameux de courir non mais il est parti
de faire 90 mètres en courant le mec
je te trouve
juste la phrase était marrante
j'ai entendu
et la transformation en face des poteaux
donc ça va faire très à 6
ça va faire il est en train de la tenir
en attendant ouais je vois
[Musique]
quelque chose
tente de cliquer en fait juste mais bon
3 à 9 c'est beaucoup
le problème
mais là on est exactement dans la
situation de la partie dont on parlait
sauf que c'est sur la 6e rangée et c'est
encore plus facile je crois qu'on avait
analysé on avait compris ça
trouver une idée pour les grands
je rappelle qu'on avait analysé ça à
fond et que ça on avait compris que le
pion aussi c'était mieux
c'est ça le truc en fait
il s'est pris le truc qu'il fallait pas
se prendre
et sur F5 il changera à prendre quoi
c'est ça
il s'est pris le truc qu'il fallait pas
se prendre
du Sénat
ça va être assez facile maintenant
terrible
c'est quand même terrible de se rendre
ça elle était pas si dur que ça des fois
mais avec peu de temps
mais il a raté de 5 aussi facile
plusieurs fois
mais oui normalement ça simplifie la vie
ouais mais à un moment donné
je peux pas ne jamais rien faire
dire tu dois trouver des coups oui
tu peux pas de ne jamais trouver de quoi
en fait
car il pourra niche
il s'est fait cliquet
allez on passe à côté de la finale de
[Musique]
ça c'est beaucoup trop facile à gagner
vous allez le voir de toute façon
bah je crois qu'on va rien voir il va
abandonner
et nous aussi
au rugby mais bon on aura une finale
demain
pas de rêve pas de rêve
on va passer à côté des neufs
c'est dommage
sauf favori quand même
ouais mais bon sinon cet état de Tilt
afin de
se mettre en PLS tout seul on sait pas
quoi
même tu sais bien repris franchement
mais il faudra peut-être pour
pour NiAl de prendre les nuls en fait
quand elle s'offre à lui et puis au pire
d'aller jusqu'en armagidon en fait
faut pas se faire chier pas faire comme
Naka en fait
il veut que des nuls t'accepte le combat
de dupe
je sais pas ce que tu en penses
bah en fait faut pas perdre tout seul
après tu peux essayer de jouer etc et
puis bon voilà mais tu peux faire le
combat du non
[Musique]
mais juste son erreur en fait c'est un
moment donné
je pense surtout de pas avoir essayé de
faire des G5 genre là il est plus que
trouvable en fait
parce que il a eu peur de F5 peut-être
plutôt
et là tu
en fait il va être obligé de
revenir vers toi
mais il a eu l'idée à plusieurs reprises
en fait même quand il avait la tour en
fait ce qu'il a fait c'est pas grave
mais c'est juste son registre qui qui
fait tellement là ça avance on s'en fout
on s'en fout ouais bah non la fois
revient
ce dont H6 tu mets les échecs derrière
et si c'est moi G4
je comprends comment il s'est fait avoir
entre guillemets
tous ressemble tout le temps tu fais une
heure de vigilance et
et voilà
[Musique]
gastronome qui perd quoi
on se retrouve demain 17h pour la suite
et le début de la finale merci à tous